morning everyone and welcome to the
committee on Health and Human Services
andly Affairs
after before we get
started I'd like you to please join me
in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic which stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank
you the first bill we'll be hearing this
morning is uh House Bill 1303 dfn and
I'd like to call forth the prime sponsor
representative rang uh the way we
usually operate here in this committee
we give the prime sponsor or extra time
to explain the Genesis of the bill and
so forth and then subsequent testimony
we limit to 3 minutes so representative
R we we welcome you
and go ahead thank you thank you very
much Mr chair and thank you committee
for allowing me this opportunity to
introduce
hb303 for the record my name is
Rosemarie rang I represent Hillsboro 12
which is the town of
marac um I have written testimony and I
will be handing it out um following my
com ments but as state reps we do big
things with big bills don't we um like
being one of the first states to pass
strict limits on pasas and drinking
water or expanding Medicaid to our most
vulnerable citizens and passing 15
billion dollar in a banial state budget
for example but passing a little bill
can be important too an HB 1303 is a
little bill it's taking
$131,000 from the state of tesque B
Banu a man who died into State and
specifying it be used by the Department
of Health and Human Services for and for
Aid to Refugee
children otherwise this money would be
deposited in the general
fund why is this little Bill important I
must tell you it is the last ditch
effort by my constituent Dr Ra Ralph
wolf to bring
Noble closure to the life of teste
brhanu Dr Wolf brought teski to the US
from an orphanage in Ethiopia where he
lived after losing his parents and his
legs in a
fire he has no living family but with
the wolf's support and devoted
friendship Mr Banu graduated from Rivier
University in 2001 with a degree in
computer science where worked as a
computer specialist and lived
independently in Nashua tragically The
Chronic pain and medical needs arising
from his amputations were overwhelming
and led to Mr bhanu's death by suicide
in August
20122 Dr Wolf worked with the New
Hampshire charitable trust Division and
the ninth circuit probate court to
memorialize Mr Banu through a UNH
scholarship but in accordance with in
State Statute the court denied that
request the Court's decision stated that
appropriating funds through the
legislative process appears to be the
most straightforward legal path and
that's what brings 1303 to you today Dr
Wolf and I agreed that
bhanu that Mr Banu would be appropriate
as the department U I'm sorry um Dr Wolf
and I agreed that directing the funds to
a department Within state government and
which serves the intent of Mr Banu would
be appropriate as the department already
operates the New Hampshire Refugee
program under the New Hampshire office
of Health Equity this bill as amended
directs any additional administrative
costs to be covered by the fund as amend
and as amended once the money's in the
fund are expended the fund
terminates so this is a little Bill that
is not asking for money that the state
is not getting anyway it's just asking
that the money be used for a specific
purpose to help children who are coming
to a new country like Mr Banu once did
this bill is however very important it
honors the life of a man who despite
facing unfathomable tragedies
contributed to the state and lived with
dignity perseverance humility and
frugality his life was very important so
I ask that you recommend HB
13303 ought to pass as amended thank you
um and I do have my written comments but
I also included the um decision um it
has a court decision and it um also has
um uh from the the ninth Circuit Court
um Mr bhanu's note that he left upon his
de prior to his death is also included
but it didn't copy very well I don't
know if you'll be able to make out um
his intent to have the money go for a
children's organization and I'd be happy
to take any questions thank
you uh yeah uh representative
Weber thank you um I tried very hard to
have this go to the Judiciary Committee
I know uh it didn't work
um with respect to the Court's opinion
would have been easier to have it
earlier so I could have read it but um
did the court actually make a decision
or does the Court's decision say that
they don't have jurisdiction to make a
change could you just explain what their
decision was when I read the decision
and represent wber I only got it last
night
so uh from from Dr Wolf but um the
decision by the probate court was that
Mr Banu died into State and following
statute that his estate goes to the
general
fund representative Murphy
I'm I'm sorry
sorry without wanting to be difficult I
I guess I want to know why it is
appropriate in this
case for us to set aside a court opinion
when we are asked regularly in this body
to set aside things like divorce
decisions and we always decline to do
that no matter how much
we might want to do other
things well in thank you for the
question in the court decision it does
state that um legislative action is the
is the most I forget the words it's on
the last page is the most
straightforward path legal path to
accomplish what Dr Wolf who I should
have mentioned he's also been the um
he's not the executive but he's the
administrator of the estate he was named
administrator so it it was the most
straightforward legal path to ensuring
that those wishes could be honored thank
you yeah thank you representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um just a question
that I don't know the answer to um is
there in statute a definition for a
refugee and um how do we Define who that
may represent and do they have to apply
for the funds in somewhere or another or
if somebody came in and had tremendous
resources was adopted had a fost
appearent would they be uh able to apply
for those funds or how would that be
distributed is there an application
process thank you very much
representative Murphy for the question
um I would defer to the Department of
Health and Human Services on that
because I didn't want to be that
prescriptive um the division of Health
Equity already administers ref two
Refugee programs so I would assume but
we know what that does I would assume
that it would be consistent with those
programs um and I I know that there are
attorneys here from the Department who
can speak more on you know how they
would manage this um so I I would defer
to them on some of the specifics thank
you representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
rang for bringing this to us uh my
question um is more about this whole
intent of just trying to make sure that
if possible this money is able to help
Refugee children um if the existing
Refugee resettlement funds are already
dealing with children as well um I guess
I'm trying to understand the necessity
to create a separate fund if children
are also included in the existing fund
you know I agree with you um when I
spoke with OSS about the intent of this
this is what they came back and I I'm
not familiar with the those other funds
or if this could have been added to
those other funds I mean that may be a a
solution I'm open-minded um my intent of
this is to honor a request by my
constituent who is Dr Wolf and his his
wife are the most generous humble
honorable people um Mr branu has not
been the only disadvantaged person
they've helped they've sponsored many um
Ethiopians to come over to this country
um Dr Wolf is probably the primary
person why there's an orthopedic surgery
program in
Ethiopia um there's a Orthopedic
Hospital and his huge portrait of him is
is when you walk in so um I trust fully
that his request to honor Mr Banu
through this is a very Val you know I I
I consider that a very honorable request
and I want to do everything I can to
make it happen but if it doesn't happen
specifically through this type of
program if it can happen another way um
I'm very agreeable to that I just want
to make sure it happens I don't want it
to get lost in in some
bureaucratic
mesh representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you m representative R for taking my
question there's a couple of things that
I see as a note in here on the bill
itself talking about the administrative
cost and the bill does not as drafted
speak to using funds for administrative
reasons to support the administrative
fund would you be amendable to changing
the bill so that funds in the fund could
be utilized administratively to support
the
cause um that thank you for that
question um sitting upstairs I just
realized is the stack of the amendment
um uh I'm sorry I will get it to you as
soon as I leave this room but it was
amended following um a a conversation I
had with representative Boyd who was a
co-sponsor I believe had a conversation
with representative Lon about this so um
there is an amendment that any
administrative cost comes out of the
fund and also when the fund is depleted
when it goes to zero the fund
terminates so I and I apologize greatly
for not having that amendment I I was so
intent on getting that Court decision to
be copied and get everything ready um
but because I was coming from my
committee another Committee hearing too
you know what it's like so I'm sorry
I'll bring that right down thank
you representative mour thank you for
taking my question so I as you mentioned
I can't read that last page but did Mr B
bhanu specifically asked for a fund to
be set up or did he want the money to go
to the children directly and I ask this
because I know that there's an
International Institute of New Hampshire
which deals directly with refugees and
so you know there would be no I don't
think a need to set up a fund when
something like that is already in
existence so would that is that a
possibility um I I wish it were but I
was at the probate court hearing and and
also reading the judge's determination
that um that note does not constitute a
will it does and there's different
versions of Wills classifications of
wills it doesn't meet any of those
standards because it wasn't witnessed um
and so the court had no um no other
option than to comply with what is
already in statute which would put it in
the general fund um I I would be you
know I'm sorry represent to get back to
to your the first part of your question
is um in the note and I'm sorry it
didn't copy well um he wanted his car to
go to Laura's World fund which is a um a
501c3 organization I actually founded it
many years ago and it serves
disadvantaged PE children around the the
the around the globe he did not mention
anything about his money and it wasn't
discovered or known until after Dr Wolf
began serving as the administrator of
the state that 100
31,000 was found in his check-in account
and this is a man that lived very
frugally um I believe he worked for the
nsha school district as a computer
specialist so he he didn't spend any
money and um but that money is
considered that his whole estate was
considered into State I actually don't
know what happened to the car but that
was the only specific request he made in
the note follow up thank you for that um
I guess so I know many volunteer efforts
um one specific there's aoka kids club
um in inner city Manchester who deal are
just bring in Refugee children um and
their families every single day and they
do it volunteer you know so I'm
wondering if if money like this could go
to a volunteer organization in which the
money there's no administrative costs
the money would go right into assisting
the children so would that ever be a
possibility as well I would support that
um Dr Wolf is here he can speak to it as
far as the intentions of Mr B i i would
support that but the way the statutes
are written now his estate has to go to
the general fund so if it goes to the
general fund and then legislatively we
take that money and allot it to an an
outside organization I'm amendable to
that but when this bill was in
initially drafted um I thought it would
make um be I guess simpler to just have
it go from this part of the general fund
to this part of a state budget so rather
than having to go outside the
state representative Merchant you had
and then representative Shapiro thank
you following up on the previous
question this touches upon the issue of
the state being responsible to
administer the fund
it sounds like you may be amendable to
allow for the state to take the funds
that are in the state treasury to have
those funds donated to a nonprofit
organization so chosen by Dr Wolf that
way there it takes the state out of the
middle and allows the funds to be
utilized based upon the will of the
Doner and not have the stake in the
middle of it would you be amendable to
Absol make an amendment to that way
absolutely representative Shapiro and
then representative Weber thank you I
was going to ask a very similar question
so I will wave off okay representative
Weber and and mine is somewhat similar
but I think it for my perspective
because I actually was for a long time
an estate planning attorney
um it seems to me that we may be able to
solve all the problems by saying that
those monies it would it would be a
complete redraft but if we said that All
the Monies which is cheet to the state
general
fund by operation of law are hereby
directed to be paid to and fill in a
voluntary organization that people are
comfortable
with yeah does that sound because that
way we have gotten around the issue of
setting aside court order we have gotten
the money into the state
funds and then we are as as our
legislative prerogative and as
representative Maser has suggested then
simply directing the state to pay some
money that it has in a direction that
the legislature wants it to pay in and
and so if we
re drafted it that way and then people
fought it out with Finance to get it to
actually happen uh would that would that
work for you absolutely um I would ask
maybe some help representative we I I
would be glad to volunteer to do the
drafting subject to some suggestions by
my friends I think the thing I would
need to be told is what organization we
want to deal with okay now I appreciate
that um and you know I I suffered from
the ignorance at the time in filing this
bill because I was under the
understanding from the judge that it had
to stay within state government that it
was going into the general fund and that
you know I could specify what part of
the general fund you know what
department but um having it go into the
general fund to be allotted to a
nonprofit I'm I I actually think that's
a better solution because of the admin
costs they work with this population
regularly um and they would have they
wouldn't be behold in um to very strict
rules or
administrative uh requirements of their
staff is that if I could
just did you name a specific
organization then when you said it no
initially when when doctor wolf first
became aware of this estate he initially
wanted a a scholarship um formed at UNH
and that got him in connection with the
New Hampshire charitable trust division
um I realized there would be a lot of
administration with the scholarship I
was and when I came on and it and it
didn't appear that that was going to
be as as simple as just directing it to
DHHS but then I see that's going to be
complicated too if we can get across the
admin cost personally I I met Mr Banu
many many years ago on a couple of
occasions um and just my own opinion and
I'll let Dr wol speak out after me but
my own opinion is that um if if if his
money could be used to make the path of
another child coming into the US easier
I think that's a very appropriate way of
Honor his me his honoring his
memory representative
tez hi thank you I I have a question am
I allowed to offer any Illuminating
information since I directed that office
for 10 years or do we do that later
that's normally you you can testify I'm
sorry I should yeah no go ahead
representative we I was just going to
clarify you can either testify by
filling in a pink card or you can
discuss it in an executive session we'll
do that that's fine thank you any other
questions seeing no other questions okay
thank you thank you very
much I also signed up to speak this
morning is representative Wendy
Thomas oh
okay I'm sorry too many pink
cards okay uh Dr
Wolf push the button so the red light
comes on please
Dr thank you for listening to
representative rang and for taking U toy
bhanu's uh uh estate uh um in this way
uh I think those of us who knew Tes
would want
his unexpectedly large estate to go to
uh a charitable Foundation either to a
university or uh to Children's Refugee
fund um he worked very hard his whole
life uh despite disability and live very
frugally and I think that is the reason
why
$131,000 is available to the state and a
charity okay thank
you you taking questions Dr Wolf sure
any questions for Dr
Wolf representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Dr Wolf for
everything you did for U this gentleman
and for others as I heard about the
surgical center um and we I think that
it would be wonderful if you also know
any Charities that you can pass along to
the members of the committee so that we
can better understand what would fulfill
the best life goals of to see Bur Anu
and um if there's anything regarding
children's uh children in Prosthetics
that might even be a closer tie I think
testi originally uh had said that part
of his estate should go to Lara's World
fund which is just a fund in marac that
uh finances scholarships at marac high
school and also does clean water
projects in Africa together with child
fund
International uh I think uh but he would
be fine as representative rung suggested
with uh a uh his money uh his estate
going to uh children's Refugee fund
administered by whoever the state thinks
is the most appropriate uh
um organization that would sidestep
administrative
costs other
questions see representative
King thank you Mr chairman and um can
you just repeat the fund that you first
said the one that uh would be supported
through marac high school I just want
make sure yes uh representative rang
founded a organization in marac called
Laura's World fund which is a devoted to
Children's uh welfare uh and we mainly
uh provide scholarships at marac high
school and uh together with child fund
International build clean water projects
in Africa
thank
you other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you oh I'm sorry
representative Weber I'm
sorry oh
okay I'm wondering if we could perhaps
refer this to a a subcommittee so that
we can um draft something and also have
a a more Nuance discussion perhaps with
representative TZ uh about uh appr rate
recipients sure and I I would offer to
do that informally but I think that this
is weighty enough and and you know we're
talking about a significant amount of
money I want I think it would be more
appropriate to have that a publicly
noticed subcommittee so that we could
sure make sure that the public can weigh
in on the initial impression of course
was that this would be was you know
right obviously it's more detailed than
we thought we actually thought we might
exec on this bill today so I'm not going
to on a subcommittee sounds very
appropriate so
thank you very much for taking the time
uh to Cy would be honored thank you Dr
will appreciate it also signed up to
speak today is John Williams and I'm
sorry I may leave the I just wanted to
point this out this a lot of money it
should be self- sustaining it should go
into a fund that generates Revenue so
that it can sustain itself for a lot
longer than just it's going to go and
again well that's why one of the Reas we
going to additional
consideration
okay okay good
morning attorney Williams and attorney
leagan welcome good morning chairman
McDonald and members of the Health Human
Services elderly Affairs committee um I
want to say Happy New Year to you all
this is our first bill for the day for
us and for you as well uh and I have to
say it's always a pleasure coming before
this committee because we came here
today uh thinking that there was a
non-legislative solution and then for
representative Weber and also over here
where representer you actually came up
with the brilliant solution about how to
actually make this happen so knowing
this is going to go to a subcommittee I
think that's very important but we do
have to lay out at least a couple of
foundational issues just to making you
aware uh first off uh the underlying
action that's involved with the probate
court with this uh very wable individual
and and I think hats off to the bill
sponsor uh I think that the bill sponsor
well- intended and Dr Wolf those kind of
efforts really are very heartfelt when
you you hear that kind of caring and and
giving to individuals however from the
standpoint of the department we're here
to talk about process primarily the
refugee resettlement program uh
currently is 100% federally funded which
means that we cannot actually administer
something like this at the state level
without the use of the resources drawing
down on this very important dollar
amount that could otherwise go to a
charity so your thoughts about getting
the Department of Health and services
completely out of the mix is actually a
stroke of Brilliance we were going to
offer to you folks and we have to be
somewhat circumspect because the
department was not a party to the
underlying action here and in addition
to that it would also look very self-
serving if we were asking to having in a
case where someone dies without a will
having money sent to the department for
us to come in and start trying to
collect on money as much as we all enjoy
those commercials over the weekend from
the secretary of state from
Massachusetts who talks about money is
Jing and calling in uh that's not
something we would ever do nor would we
have standing in this particular case
however prior to hearing this wonderful
brilliant legislative solution um uh I
have with me the wonderful attorney
Janelle Lan um and she works for the
department but I have to say with some
level of Pride she was the very first
law clerk the very first law clerk for
the perfect court system here in the
state of New Hampshire so she's very
familiar with the laws as it relates to
Probate Court both from substance as
well as procedure
and so with that said however we're not
a party to the action we represent the
state of New Hampshire so we can't be
providing legal advice but we did
believe that there was a non-legislative
solution to working with the court but I
do not want to I do not want to
frustrate represent rung who's been at
all those Court hearings or Dr Wolf
anymore since you came up with a
brilliant solution of perhaps another re
uh another Avenue to go so if you are
going to go the uh extra distance to put
something perhaps into chapter law
rather than putting it into a statutory
law directing the money that would
otherwise EST to the and I love that
word that's a fancy legal word that only
Janelle and I think represent Weber
actually knows what that meant they got
it right on the law school bar exam I'm
sure uh in in say lot but to ESET just
means that the money is going to go to
the state general funds and you can
provide probably a better legal
definition than I can around that
however I would suggest as part of your
subcommittee uh that you may want to
encourage a member from the Department
Department of Treasury because they're
going to be very much involved and they
can tell you in the same way we were
coming here today to try to help you
navigate the legal Waters of a uh leg of
a Judicial matter a matter before the
court and bringing in on an open pending
court case the legislature is something
that typically I've not seen and I'm
looking at RI Weber is not something I'm
sure she has seen in her travels here
very often as well with an open case uh
there may be a request to doing it but
there are separations of powers and
processes isues that need to be adhered
to uh that certainly getting the
Department of Treasury may be able to
give you the same outliers that we were
able to provide with a non-legislative
solution and they could at least let you
know what the language must look like
for purposes of doing what they need to
do and with that I I do have to just say
to attorney J leian who I brought here
who is going to educate us all with
girls of wisdom about all but because
you're already heading in a different
direction I don't think unless there's
questions or you know you would like to
add anything no I'll uh I'll I'll
certainly be happy to answer questions
but she elucidated me in over 30 minutes
and she's brilliant and so we'll just
let you know her testimony would have
been been
fantastic good morning representative
webar since you had a
question I think I just wanted to
clarify with either or both of you that
um what I think we're
proposing does not interfere in any way
with the court proceeding the money will
EST cheat to the
state at such time as you get a final
order and the state will be directed by
virtue of whatever we come up with
drafting as to how the money that's now
in its general fund is going to be
applied and and we can do that
specifically as relates to that which is
cheats to the state from this estate and
I think that way we are you in agreement
that if we do it that way we're not
overstepping the bounds of the court
because the Court's doing exactly what
the court is directed to do and then we
are only dealing with legislative issues
which we're allowed to
do I would agree with that
representative okay however I also canot
speak for the treasurer's office so
again to the extent that you do that as
Mr Williams indicated earlier it's a
good idea to include them in that
process because I don't know what their
process is I do not represent them but I
do think that that is a very workable
solution and follow up and if I could
just note that this is a second
committee bill and it's going to finance
and they deal with the treasury a lot
more often than we do and I and I agree
with John it's a brilliant idea I I I
think it solves a lot of the
problems other questions representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you attorney Williams for taking
the question uh this funds I believe are
going or destined to go to the
Department of Health Human
Services inside of the budget for the
Department of Health and Human Services
has this money already been earmarked
for something that if we pull it out of
the state treasury we're going to leave
a hole in the
Department's the answer is no no thank
you so no they didn't budget it because
they didn't know other questions and it
isn't going to Health and Human Services
anyway see no other questions thank you
both thank you have a thank
you I have no other um one I have no one
else signed up to testify does anyone
else wish to testify on
hb303 seeing no one I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 1303
and open the public hearing on House
Bill 1068 and recognize the prime
sponsor representative Chuck rassie from
Rochester I believe
right thank you Mr chairman members of
the
committee House Bill 16 uh 1068 is
relatively simple bill I think the title
is probably a little bit misleading
because it doesn't require any
additional testing other than what's
already required under the law all it
does is required reporting last February
Department of Health and Human Services
put out a report that basically said
that uh children are not being tested um
under the law that we currently have
where all children should be tested age
one and Age Two and they one of the
problems I actually I heard this morning
that a uh executive counselor here in
the state said that uh we are not
getting this information about how many
kids are being tested uh what this all
this bill does is basically puts a
checkbox on the U the the medical forms
which children are already required to
have when they enter a kid a child care
or a public school in the state of New
Hampshire uh so there is really no
additional requirements and it also
allows for parents to ex to opt out or
exempt out under the current law which
allows them to exempt out on on on other
things as well so there's really very
little that this does except for gives
us the information that we can the
better information to deal with children
who have lead poison in state in
Hamshire helps us a identify where lead
issues may occur it helps us identify
those students who have the problems uh
and the the students that weren't
getting tested and aren't getting tested
um now that when when they come into a
school all it requires the school
department or the uh the child care to
do is to give the parents the
information that says that this is what
you can do as far as getting your child
tested what are the hazards have led um
and that's all that's required under the
bill um that the parents be informed
and that there be a checkbox on the uh
the form that they're already um
required to uh uh to provide the school
districts when they enter School in in
in New
Hampshire I'll be happy to take any
questions so hopefully this is real
short so we can get you back on
schedule thank you so much for your
testimony and thank you for the bill am
I correct in understanding that this is
an identical Bill to a bill we passed
last year yes thank you
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Grassi for being here and
bringing more discussion to this um my
question is regarding the administrative
costs for these schools and daycares
that are already under significant
budgetary process um if they do this
electronically what it's going to cost
for them to incre add that into their
their student data they're already
requiring they're already required to
have quite a bit of student data as far
as the health forms are concerned I know
if you go into a school I worked in a
school and every time we went off
property we had our health forms with us
um this is just another basically
checkbox in there that says that the
child was tested for lead and if they
tested positive for lead uh what the
standards were and it's all protected
under HEPA uh so there's nothing that
information is going to get out to
people uh so there shouldn't be any any
major additional cost uh for any school
or uh any child care uh they're already
required to collect a large amount of
data this is just one small additional
piece followup followup um thank you for
the followup um you spoke about the need
for this data because you wanted to know
the areas where there were students who
were under tested where there may be a
higher rate of lead testing and that
information if it just resides on a form
within the school doesn't actually lead
to any of that information process we've
had a lot of other really
well-intentioned
really really thoughtful bills before us
that talk about adding something to the
process so that we can have more
information or just to be able to
provide people more privacy but every
single check box cost that money um do
you have any appropriation in order to
fund that additional cost on our local
school districts in order to cover that
cost of collecting that data and
providing it to whoever would report
this for those populationbased data that
you're looking to gather I I don't see
any addition any significant additional
cost and I don't I I mean try to you
know what it would take 15 seconds for
somebody to type in an additional box
that HHS uh DHHS would provide to them I
mean most of the information that we
have the required information they have
comes from the Health and Human Services
um and it can be done electronically or
paper forms that are all provided by
Health and Human Services and we already
have all that information available
already so it's not something that it's
new to hand hand out to people uh on the
hazards of of Leed and the requirement
that they just provide this additional
box when the doctor gets this form that
a child has to uh uh from from your uh
child uh doctor your children's doctor
when he fills out the form when your
child's getting ready to school it's
just going to be one more thing that
he's going to fill in uh so if it takes
him an extra three minutes to do
something in a medical office to prick a
finger to get a to get a blood report or
to take a drawing of blood a sample of
blood for a child uh again the law
currently says that all children ages of
one and two are supposed to be tested so
the it's already in the law so there
shouldn't be any additional
cost thank you any
other thank you Mr chair and thank you
president of grassy for taking my
question um the way I read the bill as
written if you go back and look at page
one lines
10 if they haven't had a
blood lead level test to the time of
first entry to the school they're
required to get one
help me understand if I'm coming into
the school for the first time I'm in the
ninth
grade why would I go back get a blood
level test when at that point in time
it's really meaningless um you I agree
with you ages one and two is where you
want to get to it but they're re the way
I read this if they come into the
school
system they're required to have a
documentation of a blood level test but
it doesn't say at that point in time if
they're over a certain age age is not
required it it says in there if you look
at the third line from the bottom on
page one it says for AE children ages
six years or under is and and then it
also provides an exemption unless
Exempted so it would be anyone over six
years of age I don't see it would be
required but it would be part of their
medical forms which that they would have
to provide and they need IM certain
immunizations to enter schools in the
city in the state of New
Hampshire correct that deals with child
care doesn't deal with the
school I'm referring to the school I
don't disagree with the child care on
the bottom but when you look at the one
for the schol into school you're right
right that's all just just clarification
on that saying that's all thank
you thank you for taking my question can
you describe you said this is really
just about reporting yeah um can you
describe the consequences of
not having this happening like like some
people are concerned about costs what
are the costs of missing children's who
have lead significant lead in their
blood I think it's significant and the
thing is is that the Department of
Health and Human Services put out this
report in February of February 10th
2023 uh that basically went through they
were concerned that because of covid we
had lost a lot of kids children who
weren't being tested um and that but
they weren't they weren't sure of that
if they were being tested or not they
just didn't have any way of getting that
reporting they assumed that the testing
wasn't occurring um when you take a look
at what occurs in um in our schools as
particularly with special EDS uh
sometimes the exposure to lead can give
us an indication that a child may need
special services and when you're locking
at special services you can be up to
hundreds of thousands of dollars having
work been special Le for 10 years in the
Rochester school system I know the needs
of these children and whether it be lead
exposure or uh parental drug use or
alcoholism and with their parents
whatever it's significant
cost and this is just one way hopefully
we can nip that in the bud if we can
identify at an earlier age and and maybe
this won't be a problem at all if we put
this in and we require it doctors are
going to stop waking up and saying you
know we got to get this testing done at
ages one and two or when you come in for
your check prior to going going to to
school you just get it done as a routine
um you know whatever reason it is it's
not getting done it wasn't getting done
and we've missed a number of children
and this will make sure that we get a
better compliance than we are currently
getting I'll see you this afternoon I
have another Bill thank
you
yes you did thank you very much Mr chair
and members of the committee for the
record I am representative Wendy Thomas
and I represent the town of
marac um this bill protects New
Hampshire's children by testing for lead
blood
levels why do we need this we need it to
correct a problem that has been
happening for a while lead is most often
found in houses that are built before
1978 hello North Country
this bill in particular would benefit
greatly those that live in the North
country that live in a lot of older
houses one summer my son and I walked
the length of New Hampshire we started
at Canada and went down to
Massachusetts and so we got to literally
see um many of the old houses up north
they're magnificent but they're filled
with
lead lead leads to headaches cramps
hyperactivity high blood pressure along
with brain kidney and reproductive
health
issues I would argue um based on the
earlier conversation that if a ninth
grader is coming to New Hampshire for
the first time that they would be that
we would require them to get their uh
lead blood uh level checked um because
it does uh affect the body it doesn't
the effects of lead on the body don't
stop at ages 1 to two adults uh can be
very harmed by this lead is a silent
killer it doesn't have any symptoms
initially so you don't know you're
unloading this this uh chemical into
your body it's very similar actually to
pest what we're going through lead is an
environmental toxin just like pasas
is um so what do we do um why would we
want this information and and and what's
the significance of it first is that it
identifies the source if a child comes
in with high lead in their blood then we
start looking at the house we start
looking at where they play we start
looking at different places that's the
key the Second Step In some cases not in
all but we can use um a process called
cation which is medication that it binds
to heavy metals and it can pull some of
the blood uh some of the lead out of the
blood but you have to know it's there
before you can do these treatments so
this bill serves to protect New
Hampshire's Children's Health it gives
them a chance to treat and overcome lead
exposure so that it won't impact the
rest of their lives it is a proactive
and health protective uh
step and this bill protects New
Hampshire's children oh one
second um it it uh it will help identify
those that need treatment I'm sorry I
got a little confused there and I just
wanted to read re iterate there was a
question about administrative costs when
I was a um
a a a software developer for Education
we were always shown a chart and it was
if you have a mistake in your education
at the very beginning of the development
phase it takes minutes or hours to fix
it but if you wait until the end and
it's published or something you've got a
problem and it's going to be more cost
effective if we can identify these
problems earlier we can fix them we can
help these kids and it won't lead to
kids that have significant health issues
or special education needs thank
you thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my
question I struggle with this because
this is definitely a a real concern but
I also see it as a two-prong problem
one is identifying it so you can uh
address it in the kids which is
important but then uh as you mentioned
find the source now we have another
problem because we have homeowners we
have landlords out there that are now
burdened with having to um evacuate
their house of lead and what this ends
up doing is it ends up cutting uh I know
landlords that won't rent to to low
income because of
um because of uh them having more kids
or whatever the situation might be so
how do we
handle
the the monies that are needed in order
to imediate or remediate the
houses yes representative wber we have
here a bill that has nothing to do with
remediation of lead paint in housing
stock so I I would submit that we
perhaps ought to and that would be non-
gerine to this bill so I I think I
wonder if it would be better
to stay within the four corners of the
pages representative King uh do you want
to clarify what you're trying to get out
here or well um with all due
respect it there's a there
there's we're just compounding the
problem uh if so if if we're going to
pass this bill or uh reject the bill I
think we need to understand what some of
the consequences are and so I would you
know I think we need to address that
long
term no objection okay um I'll take a
stab at this um I liken and I made
reference to this in my testimony I
liken this to um our problem with pasas
in marac um we don't know it's there
until we test once we test we have a
problem that needs to be remediated
you're
right the cost of that is falling on to
the residents of marac and I would
assume the cost in a private home would
fall upon the parents and I can't
imagine any parent who has identified in
a problem that would severely impact the
health of their child not taking action
you also mentioned uh
landlords if a res if a renter lives in
a a house let's say or a piece of
property and it has been proven to have
lead and the landlord does not address
that issue I would I would suggest
that's
criminal it it is a lifelong impacting
chemical okay thank you other
questions seeing no other questions okay
thank you very much thank
you also signed up to testify is
Michelle Roberge from the Bureau of
Health protection at the Department of
Health and Human
Services good
morning good morning can you hear me
okay I can we can good morning members
of the committee for the record my name
is Michelle robers and I'm the
administrator for the Bureau of Public
Health protection within the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services Division of Public Health
Services uh the department would like to
to thank the sponsor of the of this bill
for their interest in supporting our
vulnerable populations and I would also
like to note that the department was
pleased to collaborate with
representative Nancy Murphy and other
public health child care and Ed
education Advocates last session on a
similar Bill HB 342 uh to improve lead
testing rates while reducing the impact
on schools and child care facilities
blood testing is a is critically
important to ensure the the health of
children in New Hampshire as the only
way to know if a child is poisoned by
lead is through a blood lead test the
Bill's intent is to bring awareness and
provide educational opportunities to
parents on the importance of blood lead
testing any amount of blood any excuse
me any amount of lead in a child's blood
is dangerous and can cause Health
cognitive impairment and behavioral
problems these health effects are more
harmful to young children because their
bodies are still developing and growing
young children often put their hands or
other objects like toys which may be
contaminated with lead dust into their
mouths so they're more likely to be
directly exposed to lead than older
children by testing at ages one and two
parents and health care providers can
learn if mitigation strategies are
needed to reduce further exposure prior
to negative health effects understate
law CH all children in New Hampshire are
required to have blood Le level tests at
age one and again at age two the
department also recommends blood lead
level testing for children ages 3 to six
who have not been tested at ages 1 and
two according to the Centers for Disease
Control and prevention similar lead
testing requirements exist for all
children who are enrolled in Medicaid
and the American Academy of Pediatrics
uh recommends that providers test
asymptomatic children for elevated blood
lead concentrations according to F
federal state and local
requirements as noted in the
Department's lead exposure data brief in
2021 5,000
360 fewer children had blood Le tests
completed since
2019 this was largely due to the
covid-19 pandemic and a nationwide
recall of in-office blood Le testing
supplies this represented 25 a 25% drop
in the number of children tested in New
Hampshire for blood lead levels since
2019 I'd just like to note that similar
efforts have already been established uh
in the City of Claremont The Claremont
School Board instituted a policy in 2017
that required both the one and the
two-year-old blood blood level tests be
documented on the physical examination
form for entry to prek and kindergarten
could you start wrapping up please yes
thank you for the opportunity to provide
this testimony the department
appreciates the sponsors uh support for
improving blood blood testing rates but
we also understand that schools May have
competing responsibilities and I'd just
like to note that the department can
help schools in daycares with any
educational materials that um this bill
may may require and and I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you
representative
Weber thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question is there any
update on what's happened with the uh
lead testing machines they were recalled
have they been replace do we know it yes
um my understanding is is that the
machines themselves weren't involved in
the recall it was the materials that are
used uh to uh collect the sample and a
lot of that was like some of the
Plastics material so my understanding is
yes that's all been resolved and so the
recall so the machines are still
effective and can be used with the new
um supplies Supply kits representative
Lon um thank you Mr chairman and thank
you very much for being here with
information uh my question is regarding
the more population Health surveillance
that was referenced by the prime sponsor
of this bill is the department looking
to have information so they can locate
areas where there are children who have
a higher blood level concentrations yes
we do on an annual basis we put out the
lead data brief the Department issues a
lead data brief we are due the 2022 lead
data brief has been uh slightly delayed
due to um we had a um a staffing issue
in terms of Staffing uh shortage so we
are working on that and we'll have that
new le data brief the numbers that I
provided in my testimony are from the
2021 Le data brief and it will be shared
with all the 2022 data brief will be
shared with all of you once the
department has finalized it and issued
it follow follow up um thank you and as
a followup are you looking for the
schools and the daycare providers to
provide the information on um student
testing rates and um how many of them
high have high blood levels obviously on
a personal data data neutral basis but
are you looking to get this information
from these providers no we we
automatically get the information from
uh providers either medical providers or
Laboratories that's required to be
submitted to the department as part of
our blood Le surveillance uh system so
we get that information uh automatically
in my understanding when I read the
language of the bill there's no
requirements for schools or daycares to
submit that information to the
department that would be redundant
because we already get that my
understanding is the the goal of the
bill is to to um where schools you know
where schools are working with families
sort of on the ground it gets an
opportunity if a child has not been
tested it gets an opportunity to provide
education to the parents on the
importance of blood blood testing so
it's my understanding as the as I read I
read the bill um and I also notice that
in the bill uh for schools um on line 10
of the bill it does say uh ages six and
under and that's also that's for public
schools and then on line 26 of the bill
it's also aged one and 1 to six years
old for um Child Care
Facilities other
questions I'm saying no other questions
thank you very much thank you very
much no one else has signed up to
testify on house build 1068 does anyone
else wish to
testify
seeing no one else I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 1068
and open the uh public hearing on House
Bill
1318 and recognize our very own
Committee Member representative David
Nagel the prime
sponsor
not to be sexist but my wife's away so I
really needed to be bossed
around wow this is a
stadium holy cow um thank you Mr
chairman and it's an honor to be here
I'm also pleased that uh attorney buetti
is also here um he's done an awful lot
of work on this project and um he's
really the expert on the
actual um aatman trust fund that we're
going to be talking about um I think
it's an incredibly sad yet fortunate
tragedy that we heard about um the
suicide of Mr Banu earlier today from um
um IR intractable pain um it's sad
because it's a story that happens over
and over again um I am going to deviate
a little bit from the script that I gave
you because this morning when I woke up
at 5:30 um I realized that you might not
even know what the opioid abatement
trust fund is do you does anybody okay
um so I'll just as a beginning um I'm a
physician as you know I'm also a
representative last I checked uh I
specialize in physical medicine and
rehabilitation pain management and
acupuncture and I've done this for over
over 35 years my credentials are on the
rest of the testimony I don't want to go
over those in detail you can read them
for yourselves um you all have heard
them before um what I have done is
advocated for the rights of people in
pain for over 30 years focusing on the
stigmatized and disenfranchised and
trying to change the way we perceive
judge and treat
pain um in a s I have the heavy burden
today of of representing the 66 million
people who suffer from chronic pain the
1.5 million in hospice care every year
who suffer with pain too often with
their needs unmet um because of
unfortunate public policies over the
last couple years and 50 million people
who have surgery this year who require
opioids for care of their surgery and
the unknown tens of millions of people
every year that will have moderate to
severe pain I've also been told that I
can um state that I'm representing the
United States pain foundation and I also
represent the New Hampshire pain
collaborative in this
endeavor
so what's the opioid abatement trust
fund so this is my cynical look at a lot
of things um whenever there's a crisis
um and this is a direct reference to a
South Park episode which was referenced
on the house floor previously whenever
there's a crisis it's critical we find
one entity to blame no matter the
culpability of others um the reasons for
the opioid crisis were
complex um I think we one of the largest
reasons is we do a rotten job in our
country of managing pain and treating
people in pain that dates back to the
Harrison Act of
1914 um that act um was as a result of
an opioid crisis that happened at that
time the net result of that based on
subsequent Supreme Court interpretations
is that people in pain were vilified
looked as people as a character flaw
addiction became a crime and Physicians
that had dared to prescribe any pain
medicine for patients were then viewed
as criminals that that La that the
results of that still last to today
um um in the mid1 1980s after nearly a
century of prohibition we realized that
some some some patients with chronic
pain and most patients with pain at the
end of life can benefit from opioid
therapy as part of a balanced
comprehensive integrative care plan
somehow unfortunately Society always
seeks a Magic Bullet um and opioids
became that magic bullet which was not
consistent with the message that we were
providing in the early ' 880s and '90s
and I've been involved in this
discussion since the early '90s and '
80s the media fan the Flames there are a
number of Articles covers of newspapers
saying that you didn't have to suffer
you could just take pain medicine you
don't even need to do all those other
things like exercise psych things
anything like that just take a pill and
you'd be fine of course they don't
accept the blame for that now um um the
patients suddenly did not willing to
suffer they were not willing they
demanded the access to opioids and
prescri description Skyrocket and his
side effects which were more often than
not multifactorial it wasn't merely just
taking a pain pill that created the
problem it was much more than that also
we observed that addicts flocked to this
new free source of drug the CDC then
declared this as a pandemic using
tobacco legislation as a model Justice
departments leapt into action focusing
most of the blame on the pharmaceutical
industry despite the culpability of
others lawsuits were filed and I say
under many false pretenses and we I'd be
happy to discuss that in Greater detail
if you wish the dollars that were subst
we collected were placed into opioid
abat trust funds to be managed state
byst state under a series of guidelines
created by the
settlement my observation from where I
sit is that dollars were shifted from
those in pain to those um with addiction
and my concern about this is that my big
effort throughout my life is to create a
balance between the needs of both the
balance shifted we ref refer to that as
a pendulum and suddenly one group was
being harmed another group was being in
theory helped um we the chapter on that
has yet to be written as to whether
that's true or not um let's
see this is my other concern about the
process and this is a painful thing for
me and this is the first time I'm saying
this publicly now I've been told it's
safe to do so as part of the process
anyone who'd ever received any money
from Pharma was called into question
nonprofits and professional
organizations were hauled into court at
substantial cost many going bankrupt in
the process um or giving the fight for a
worthy cause um seeking to help those in
pain my personal story was that when I
saw what was going on the myopia of
blaming one entity and and and causing
harm to people in pain was that I wrote
an oped because when I get ticked I
write and that's what I did I shared
this with a bunch of people and I was
informed don't you dare publish this and
do not tell anybody what you've done in
this state for people in pain because
the minute you do they will haul you
into court and they will destroy you I
saw this over and over and over again I
I work with the center for practical
bioethics in Kansas City this
organization walks on water they totally
change the way we as a society deal with
the issue of end of life pain they
accepted money from Purdue
pharmaceutical a minor amount they were
called into court to justify that money
that they received and as a result they
nearly went bankrupt it they ended up
having to give up any mention of pain in
any of their Endeavors that they do even
to this date they can't do that because
of these settlements and things like
that that is really inappropriate the
other thing that that concerns me also
is that um we weren't able to care for
people in pain a number of professional
organizations Dr Murphy's an orthopedic
surgeon you know that um um um people
people that make surgical supplies
support all your meetings
correct they well who else did
pharmaceutical companies do well all of
a sudden we lost all that money not only
that the American uh pain Society the
American acad pain medicine and other
pain organizations cease to exist
because of legal costs because of this
process now where do we go to get our
education how do we advocate for the
rights of people five advocacy
organizations cease to exist who
advocates for their rights anyways you
got me going that's my
catharsis um with that said I want to
share one story and then I'll get to
what the gist of the bill is about so
there's this gentleman Doug hail um I'm
I can say his name because he actually
his suicide note was actually published
in the pain News Network at the at the
request of his estate so there's nothing
I'm going to tell you that was not in
his suicide note he lived in Vermont on
the New Hampshire border he re received
his primary care in Vermont his
Specialty Care in New Hampshire um he
had chronic pain from multiple sources
for about 20 years and he was on
methadone maintenance for that entire
period of time because of pressure
because of public policies not just from
the opio abatement issue but from the
CDC and other things there's a lot of
pressure on doctors to not prescribe the
doctor that was caring for him I think
walked on water I mean he was a bril a
wonderful man and the only reason I know
this was I was asked to testify as an
expert witness at a wrongful death suit
I reviewed 2500 pages of medical notes
um basically um what I found was the
doctor did everything right but he was
getting so much pressure from other
people he finally succumbed and he
submitted this patient to non-consensual
dose
reduction the patient was then admitted
to a a rehab place received a Six-Day
detox from 20 years of methadone I will
not State publicly what I think about
that but that's pretty inappropriate he
then went home um within a week he
couldn't Sur he couldn't deal with it
and like our Mr Banu took a
gun
dead and then the suicide note was found
later his wife published that in the
pain Network news and I it's and
unfortunately we hear these stories over
and over and over and over again my
concerns then becomes is well what do we
do about them you know who speaks for
them and to me the opio abatement funds
I think that I'm really concerned about
why they were created I think that blame
was I'm not saying the pharmaceutical
industry is Innocent but there's a lot
of other blame to go around and and I
think to just focus that blame on one
group is is is not good with that said
that money needs to be used for a higher
purpose and to me the critical thing
that we need to do is balance this
system when I saw the original bill on
that created the opioid abatement
commission and the reason I saw it was
it was in the Omnibus Bill you all
passed during covid my bill that I'd
work for five years was in that and when
I saw the bill and I looked at it and I
saw the serious Omission from anything
that had anything to do with people in
pain I was like you know what I would
have voted against the ominous Bill and
let my bill die I was so concerned about
that so what I wanted to do with this
bill and being on the opioid abatement
commission I forgot to tell you I'm the
vice
um was to try to bring some sort of
balance so with that said I really
respect attorney buffetti he's a really
smart guy and he knows the settlements
backwards forwards sideways and
everywhere and I do respect his concerns
I'm sorry I'm speaking for you here but
anyways I do respect his concerns that
the money we spend has to respect the
opioid settlements that were created um
that is actually in a 500 page um um
statement please which I have 10 pages
here yeah I'm going to read the whole
thing but this is exhibit e that
outlines what can be used and then this
is the John Hopkins primer that's used
by state abatement trust fund
commissions to decide what they can and
they can't use it for so what we did as
a group is we created a subcommittee to
decide whether the two issues that I
have in the bill could be included
within this because it's actually not in
the Johns Hopkins um primer which kind
of really surprised me a lot um with
that said we went through through it and
we did come you're you're going to see
the second or the attachment that I gave
to you is the primer and on that it
actually is the justification from
exhibit e as to why these these bills
are acceptable so the next question is I
really love our committee commission
whatever um everybody on it's really
wonderful thoughtful everybody has a an
addiction story everybody has a pain
story and we have really great
discussions and I trust them thoroughly
you know to in consider including things
like this for example we passed HB 66
last year which is representative
Merchants bill um that I had something
to do with and um we created a uh an
alternative to opioids basically pilot
program is what we're doing first in the
nation maybe to try to find alternative
ways to deal with pain that may or may
not involve opioids um things like that
I think should be funded by the opioid
abatement thing because it's both a harm
reduction strategy but it's also helpful
for people that are being omitted
um so that that's what's in there and
that's why I created this I do have
faith but the problem is is that this is
a long-term process I think to respect
the people that I think that are being
omitted that a statutory change to
include these two things that I've added
into the 17 current recommendations is
important and also because this
commission is going to be a moving
Target it's not always going to be the
same the priorities are going to change
and that's why we created the
subcommittee and why we we've created
discussions is to try to formalize what
we think are priorities for this money
um and I think that's pretty much all I
have to say I probably went over five
minutes and um um but I'd be happy
sponsor we give extra time to I know I
know I'd be happy to take any questions
any questions for representative Nagel
representative
Weber as I hear it and I will just say
that I am somebody who looked after
somebody with tractable pain for four
years uh as my husband died of prostate
cancer
um what I am wrestling with here is and
I have not had time to read all those
materials obviously but it my
understanding of the opioid abatement
fund was always that it
addressed that the point of it was
always to
address
the addiction side of things rather than
the pain control side of things and I I
I understand your your point about the
pendulum and what we have done to
patients who are in
pain but I'm hoping that have the
materials that you have given us pointed
specifically to where in the settlement
it allows these things to be used for
this purpose because it seems to be a
radical departure from my understanding
of the opioid abatement fund that is a
really very intuitive and wonderful
question and it's something that we
wrestled with a lot especially in my
subcommittee and me personally because
this obviously an important issue to me
um this is the John's Hopkins primer
I'll throw it of you of an airplane and
you can read the whole thing in three
minutes but basically what it does is it
outlines the priorities and you guys
I've already been informed that you guys
are getting sick of hearing about harm
reduction but um but there's there's a
number of techniques that are being used
for opioid abatement so basic you know
one of them is prevention and and that's
probably the one element of the O entire
opioid abatement trust nationally that
people are kind of ignoring because
we're really weak on
prevention I would argue and and and and
and you when you look through what I
wrote you will see the justification
based on exist for what I'm proposing
like we need data on on on on how many
PE people have chronic pain why they
commit suicide um I will tell you right
now that a lot of the data that you're
hearing is totally misguided for example
we hear that 12 million people per year
suffer from um or have opio misuse
opioids um what's kind of Forgotten in
that discussion is 70% of them are
treating a problem that they're not um
receiving care for so to me um
prevention includes well how do we
include them into the process we know
that comprehensive integrative Services
work to prevent opioid use in people
with pain so why don't we pay for that
you know why don't we explore that I
mean the HB 66 I think was an incredibly
novel way to try to do that and try to
prevent people from turning to opioids
and when people don't receive opioids on
the Street and I've said this in the
committee before and I will say it again
if you don't treat somebody with pain
and I had an 83-year-old lady come up to
me once and tell me I'm 83 years old
I've lived a full life I don't need to
suffer I will go to the street and I
will buy my perco set there and I looked
at her and I said well that's not a
great way to do it but we as a society
turn people to the streets so I have
patients now that are getting fentanyl
tinged opioids from the street and dying
so to me finding better strategies to
deal with the pain at its base is a
preventative strategy that I did justify
by using exhibit e um and the other big
group that we have to deal with are the
opioid refugees people that were being
managed just
fine and then all of a sudden don't have
access to care because their doctors are
afraid to prescribe to them so what do
they do they die they go to the street
or they suffer and that's not really
fair to them but when they go to the
street what happens personally I was
told that we can't do that because um
you know well we can't this thing
doesn't deal with giving drugs to people
you know to treat their pain I I I
wanted to create an mat type program for
people like that that is in my
recommendations um well I said well we
give opioids to people on mat all the
time buper Norine methadone we do it all
the time so what's the difference now
we're actually treating a problem not an
addiction we're deing a pain problem not
an addiction problem to me it's the same
thing they end up in the same place does
that answer your question it does
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative Nel for taking the
question I do occur that the intent of
the opiate abatement was to deal with
addiction but it reminds me of an
analogy someone shared with me before it
was kind of like a bathtub filled with
water if you try to figure out how to
drain the bathtub if you look at what's
going out we need to be cognitive of
that which is back to treating the
addiction to minimize what's in there at
the same time though I think we have a
need to minimize the amount of water
going into the bathtub which is the ones
who now become addicted because of
mismanagement because they go to
something along opiates can you speak to
the issue of that dichotomy where on one
side of the coin you want to stop the
issue of addiction
but you also want to control or try to
prevent people from becoming
addicted I mean when I it's really weird
one of the things that I learned on the
opioid abatement commission is if you
look at the percentage of people who are
homeless the percentage of people are
incarcerated have a substance use
disorder it's roughly 75 to 80% that was
like a shocking number to me so you know
one of the thoughts was well let's treat
it in the prison and I says well why
don't we prevent it before they get get
to the prison so a lot of people have
you know on the committee this you know
I thought $300 million is a lot of money
I mean you know I I I I have that in my
car right now which is in my suit coat
that's actually in my car sorry but um
you know $300 million I thought was a
lot of money then I found out it's
really not a lot of money when you're
dealing with a problem that that's this
big but so we all have our points of
view well how do we you know spend that
and to me when I looked at that
statistic alone it really struck me that
we really need to focus us on prevention
and um and how you do that in an
evidence-based way which is one of the
requirements of the statute is is where
things get complex I mean what
preventative strategies have evidence
base and but at the same point it's
important we need to look at that and to
me treating people in pain if we think
that they were the Genesis of the opioid
problem in the first place why wouldn't
we want to do whatever we can do to
prevent them from going on opioids in
the first place so why don't we provide
comprehensive integrative programs as
oppos to just pills and procedures and
tell them you know what this pill or
this procedure will work it'd be fine
and it doesn't we know it doesn't so why
don't we spend our money there that's my
opinion
followup thank you Mr jar and thank you
for taking the question the followup
question is that in the house bill 66
when we had the meetings one of the
things we learned from the industry
itself was a desire to find
Solutions but one of the issues they ran
into is as a private for-profit
organization is the risk of Financial
Risk so therefore it's one of those
things where I think where the
government at times can be very helpful
is taking some of the Financial Risk on
a pilot program in order to show that
something works therefore it does become
something the industry could adopt
because they don't have to get into the
Financial Risk and you speak to that for
me please you don't want me to talk for
hours on that one um
that's a long discussion I mean in 1975
Milton Friedman said that the practice
of medicine was a monopoly period and
that it should be subject to Monopoly
regulation um how we spend money in
medicine is too often dependent on who
has the power and where that money goes
um people in comprehensive integrative
programs typically don't have that level
of power they don't generate a lot of
Revenue and therefore it's hard for us
to make those kinds of decisions which
is why I proposed very publicly in my
book that we need to turn the practice
of Health Care upside down and focus on
how we deal with issues of managing
problems preventing problems especially
substance to use pain um disability
things like that I mean
there's that's my nutshell of an answer
but right now we have a system that
functions against that um you know you
know who controls the power in in
healthcare everybody knows that and
that's got to change if it doesn't
change then everything we're doing is a
waste of time but I think this is not a
waste of time for me
personally representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and thank
you um for taking this question and I
realized I came in late so I may be
putting my foot in my mouth um so it it
appears to me that what this bill does
is it adds at least one category or a
broader category of things that the um
opioid abatement
commission can respond to with grants of
money so it's
um it's adding it's not taking away
anything and um and I I heard you get
your um what I thought was a brilliant
explanation of why this is part of
prevention um which is already in um
which is already one of the categories
so could you just explain to to me um a
little bit
about you know less less PE lest people
think that well now all the money will
go into this versus going into um um
medically assisted treatment or or um
other kinds of
um harm reduction whatever harm
reduction is um how does the commission
make decisions about how many grants or
how much money will be given to to this
area and how many how much will be given
to this area um can we be assured that
there's going to still be uh you know a
very broad view of of how this large
amount of money which is not as large as
we thought can be used that's a really
great question and and again I I'm gonna
I know we don't always agree on stuff
but attorney buffetti is the expert on
that so maybe he can ask answer that too
but I'll give you my answer so um you
know it's a lot of money
the first step is you have to ask for it
once somebody's asked for it and the
process by doing that very state by
state our state has a very specific way
other states do it differently but once
the money is asked for then it goes into
the committee and then the committee I
don't even remember how many people are
on it's a fairly large group um um you
know we we it may get submitted to a sub
subcommittee which is what I saw the
first time and then they make
recommendations the committee as a whole
whether they think it's a good idea or
not and then based on and whether it
also the critical thing does it fall
within the guidelines because if it
doesn't then it you know we we risk
losing money if if we give money away
that's not within the guidelines so the
committee votes yes or no if the
committee votes yes then the next step
is it has to go to the governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other DRS
drugs and and several people from that
are on the committee the commission as
well and then if they accept it then it
goes to the executive Council then the
executive Council has to approve it so
it's extremely complicated process in
other states they don't do it that way
the opioid abatement commission has
total control I think 12 states do it
that way most of the states that
actually have commissions will will do
it the way I just described so it's very
diff it's a complicated process and it's
very time consuming so you know I was
told and I and I really respect this
that um that you know we believe that
right now we have we don't need the leg
legislation because we can do this um I
am not at all convinced that that's true
I what I would like to see is that um
that these two things be included as
potentials but they're not going to
overwhelm all the other things you know
at all um and despite the vote in the
house the other day harm reduction
actually is one of the the um
criteria thank you um before I call on
representative Weber um obviously we're
running behind but yeah I'm sorry uh
other other questions after
representative Weber maybe we could
defer to a regular committee meeting
because obviously we have the prime
witness right here uh and we'll have
read readily available access but go
ahead representative
Weber before I ask my question could I
also ask you a procedural thing sure uh
which is that I'm certainly finding that
I would need more time to think about
this question because um
the witness has brought up a number of
things that I hadn't thought about
before so I'm wondering if if we can
make up time by by not exing it today I
I know that it's on for exec today but I
I just wanted to express my own feeling
that it's a more complicated subject
than I than I thought so um I just offer
that as a suggestion I don't know how
other people feel but I'm I'm certainly
feeling that way so with that if I could
ask my question which
is um given that number 15 which is
already in
here um about evidencebased and
evidence-based and evidence and formed
primary secary and tertiary prevention
programs and services including efforts
to promote Healthy Lifestyles reduce
isolation build skills resilience and
facilitate community-based Prov
prevention
efforts when we're talking about
prevention efforts isn't isn't this
already in
there um to answer that question um I I
um I have not read the minutes of every
commission meeting I've been on the
commission for a little over a year but
what became quite apparent to me and um
again attorney buetti can correct me if
I'm wrong because I may very well be but
um the issue of using these funds to
address the issues I've raised today has
never been brought up and and be and
that is why my concern was that these
two issues would not be included under
that category of 15 when I first started
um I said oh boy this is great if we get
harm reduction in there and we used 15
which was actually added also um with
those two things I thought that was good
enough but then it became quite apparent
to me in some of the committee dis
commission discussions we've had it it
wasn't and that's why I felt it was was
necessary to take this extra step do I
have faith that our current group would
approve representative Merchant's
brilliant idea program um I think that
they would certainly consider it but in
five years a different commission may
not and that's why I thought it was
important okay um again other questions
uh we we will continue this we won't
execute today uh representative Weber
makes a good point and clearly this a
lot of um it's a complex Bill and a lot
of uh concern about it
so um just one quick statement um
representative Murphy would appreciate
this but most doctors um try to clate
Simplicity out of complexity physiatrist
try to create complexity out of
simplicity so I just did that for you
okay all right um with that uh I think
we're all set representative Nagel if
you want
to um step down and also signed up to
speak today is Attorney James buffetti
from the New Hampshire Department of
Justice I I don't good morning and
usually what we do attorney beretti is
it's three minutes for Testimony after
the prime sponsor but obviously you can
take questions and hopefully we'll
address through that process if there's
any additional comments fine um thank
you uh for the record my name is James
buffetti I am the deputy attorney
general uh since 2014 I have been the
state's lead prosecutor in all of its uh
opioid litigation I'm also a member of
the opioid abatement
commission um so the opioid abatement
trust fund if you read the statute it it
contains all of the settlement funds
from uh from judgments against opioid
manufacturers and Distributors there
were multiple cases brought by the state
and multiple settlements against a whole
variety of opioid manufacturers and
opioid um
U other companies that that are doing
this in total uh I think we will receive
over 18 years about $300 million which
is for the purpose of opioid abatement
and so opioid abatement this this money
is designed and limited to opioid
abatement which is to provide treatment
resources to people who are suffering
from opioid use disorder to prevent
people from dying of opioid overdoses
and to uh to address what in New
Hampshire was a very significant problem
at one point New Hampshire was um the
the second highest overdose rate uh per
capita in the country after West
Virginia and so we have spent a lot of
time addressing it these settlements are
designed to uh to deal with opioid
abatement and and not anything else and
in fact that if we did something outside
of opioid abatement we would jeopardize
These funds going
forward so here's my concern my concern
is that the
language of this stat of this bill is uh
is open to a lot of interpretation and
is somewhat vague it talks about
increasing access I'm not sure if it's
increasing access to
opioids uh but it talks about those who
have who have um who who been were
subject to non-consensual dose
reduction to the extent that this
language could be interpreted as as
increasing the supply of opioids that
would be completely contrary to the
purposes of these funds and I'm here to
tell you that that would jeopardize the
the the ongoing receipt of these funds
these funds are limited by settlements
that have been approved by courts
including bankruptcy courts many of
these companies file bankruptcy and
there are there were limitations in the
bankruptcy orders um so but two to the
extent that that the the that this bill
is intending to to
deal with uh with issues like treatment
and withdrawal Services I would say that
if you look at the existing statute all
that stuff is already there and that we
don't we don't need this bill if you
look at 126 um uh
a86 the statute currently talks about uh
medications for substance use disorder
abstinence-based treatment treatment and
Recovery it talks about emergency
response Services related to opioid use
disorder it talks about talks about um
withdrawal Management Services about FDA
approved opioid reversal agents it talks
about H reduction programs and it talks
about efforts to prevent
overprescribing to ensure appropriate
prescribing and dispensing of opioids
through evidence-based and other uh
evidence informed programs or strategies
I mean his here's the reality you know
and start wrapping up I've been involved
in these cases uh and we've we've
heavily litigated these cases against
puru Johnson and Johnson malen crot
other companies there's overwhelming
evidence that the reason that we're in
the situation that we are it was a was a
grossly
overprescribing of opioids it was a
culture that was created by Purdue
pharmer and other companies to encourage
doctors to prescribe opioids for
everything and if you look at the
evidence the evidence is that these
companies flooded New Hampshire with
opioids and that we had so many opioids
that that we we we we uh were subject to
the the uh the uh misuse and the
overdose rates that we've seen so so to
the extent that this bill is in any way
interpreted as saying that that we can
use it to provide more opioids to people
we are going to run into problems going
forward with these settlements thank you
very much any questions representative
Lon um thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for being here with this information
we would love to have you on some of the
others when we were talking about
spending this settlement money um so my
question for you is regarding the fact
that patients who are at either
certainly facing end of life or without
appropriate care will unfortunately
become end of life and they're being
denied opiates when they have something
like say a softball siiz abscess that is
reached into their bone and they're
intractable pain and because of all of
the efforts surrounding this they are
not on an opioid that would relieve that
pain and allow their body to recover but
are instead on something like
Tramadol um I'm trying to understand how
the Mis it's a misuse of opioid and it's
not NE it's it would be outside of the
scope of this in order to ensure that
those people who quite honestly if they
survive long enough to have an addiction
problem are probably a success story but
instead we're trying to make sure that
they're not dying in a Agony how that
would be contrary to these settlements
well first of all um doctors are
perfectly free to prescribe opioids this
these cases have never been about not
prescribing opioids this has been the
overprescribing of opioids for chronic
pain patients not for end of life
patients C breakthrough cancer pain
patients so they can they can still
prescribe what they need to and I am not
not unsympathetic to what Dr Nagel is
talking about all I'm here to say is
that you can't use this money for that
purpose they may be other programs that
should be used to to to to support those
efforts but that's not what this money
was intended for so it's not really
question of is this right and is this
wrong the question is can you use this
money for this purpose and I think the
answer is no that you can't if if it's
if it's for the The increased Supply if
you if the money is used to purchase
more opioids to provide more opioids to
patients who may very well need it you
can't use this money for that
purpose followup um thank you and as a
followup um respectfully doctors are
being essentially prohibited from
prescribing opioids in those groups do
you think that c that pre preventing
that harm is is outside of the scope
well I I don't I'd be interesting in a
follow-up conversation with you maybe
outside of this room as to who is
preventing doctors from prescribing
opioids for end of life care or
breakthrough pant a cancer pain pain uh
I I I'm not aware of that that was never
the target of these cases ever so if
that's happening that's a question that
should be raised maybe with with other
with the Board of Medicine and with
others I'm not aware of that and that
frankly shouldn't be happening because
that's not what the purpose of all these
lawsuits
was represent
Weber I believe representative Merchant
was I'm line before me thank you thank
you Mr chairman and also thank you
attorney Petty for taking my question
I'll go back to my analogy about the
bathtub and what I'm trying to get to is
that this tremendous amount of focus
based upon this conversation I'm trying
to drain the bathtu and talking about
addiction which I totally think is
important but we're not at all beginning
to wrestle with the issue with water
going in the bathtub and that gets back
into the issue of trying to find ways to
help patients not have to use opiates
and if we don't find a way to do that
what are we going to do because
ultimately that's the easy way it's a
silver bullet it's cheap it's
inexpensive but we don't have any
alternatives we haven't been able to
document it so help me understand about
funds trying to use the funds in a way
to prevent water coming into the bathtub
just for f using on the water going out
of the bathtub well the the the current
statute absolutely allows for prevention
to prevent people from from from using
opioids in the first instance if if the
commission wants to fund a program for
that in the schools or in in any place
else we C that's certainly within the
Gambit of how these opioids monies uh
should be used and how they were
intended
followup
you talk about
prevention but at the same time and I'll
go back to I think what the settlement
was about I wasn't there obviously I
wasn't the attorney was inappropriate
prescribing of opius not that opius
didn't have a place it's a question of
utilizing them inappropriately what
we're trying to accomplish by having
funds from the opiate abatement program
is to allow for us to create the
environment that allows for appropriate
prescribing of opiates but at the same
time allow for people to get
alternatives to opiates so I don't
understand where the objections coming
from because within what I'm hearing
that's within the context of what we're
talking about all this bill does is
clarifies it does it not frankly I'm not
sure what this bill does and that's my
concern the language is not clear if it
would allow here's my only concern and I
think we could work on language with Dr
Nel here's my only concern to the extent
that the language would allow for funds
to be used to increase the supply of
opioids to provide opioids to patients
that I think would run against the
purposes of the
statute just I just want to be clear
that you keep using the word I keep
hearing the word increasing opiates what
I'm hearing sort
of silently in that comment is the fact
is we don't want opiates period and
that's totally different than
appropriate prescribing of opiates so I
want to be clear that we're down the
road of appropriate prescribing not
inappropriate prescribing so is that my
understanding of what you were trying to
communicate here so the statute already
provides for appropriate prescribing uh
so no I'm not saying that that no opioid
we've never said that opioids have no
use in treatment of pain but and this
case is not about overprescribing this
case was about unfair and decep ceptive
business practices by the opioid
manufacturers who then flooded our
communities with opioids flooded them
and so that's what this is about this
was never geared toward the prescribers
the prescribers were fed a bunch of
false information from the opioid
manufacturers who told them that these
drugs were safe effective and
non-addictive when they knew that was a
lie and they and they went to doctors
over and over again sometimes three
times a week and fed them a bunch of
Lies and so they got caught in their
lies and they paid dear some of them
went to bankruptcy they paid dear for I
mean billions of dollars because what
they were doing was clearly a violation
of consumer protection acts they were
deceiving people and thinking these
drugs were safe effective and
non-addictive for chronic pain patients
and that was not
true representative Weber well as a as a
followup both I think to representative
Merchant and also I think to
representative leyon and
recognizing that um I think many of us
have experienced the issue of people
with chronic pain who are now are not
able to get treated so that's and
irrespective of how we got here the
question now is what do we do going
forward so what I'm wondering
is could would you be willing to issue
us a legal opinion
that passing this is going to contravene
the terms of the settlements which are
the governing document for the
funds and what I also seem to hear you
saying is with
clarification this
may be able to be brought within the
parameters of the settlement and would
you be willing to help us by providing
US Written guidance as to what could be
done within the parameters of the
settlement funds in your legal opinion
because that's what we don't have the
expertise to deal with sure I'm I'm
happy to work with the with the
committee again my point is is a a
fairly narrow one it it as long as the
language is clear that you couldn't use
this money to to provide opioids to
people you couldn't do that you could do
all sorts of other things in terms of
treatment of pain and alternatives to
treatment of pain and getting people off
opioids but you couldn't use the money
to increase the supply of opioids so
none of this language which doesn't
doesn't say that directly but it but but
I'm concerned about how this is
interpreted down the road by other
commissions but if you're talking about
increasing access what does that mean uh
what it what it in my my opinion what it
cannot mean is that we use it to supply
opioids to to to to patients who who who
needed representative Seth King thank
you Mr chair and thank you Assistant
Attorney General for taking questions I
I think I actually understand where
you're coming from on this um
unfortunately it seems like the debate
is about the efficacy or legitimacy of
opioids when all you're really basically
saying if I if I have it understood
correctly is that um the language of
this bill doesn't belong in the opioid
opioid advisement uh abatement
advisement committee advisory committee
commission and um but but you you said a
a couple times that it really can't be
in there and it sounds like there was a
lawsuit there was litigation there was
settlement and to put this language in
there would really Contra contravene the
whole point of the the lawsuit and the
litigation and all that um so my my
question is if this were to pass and get
signed by the governor do you think this
would hold up in court would there be
would there be um litigation now to to
to over overturn this law and who would
file that sort of litigation I mean I
can't imagine the opioid companies would
say oh we need to get rid of this here
who who would have to then you know
initiate a lawsuit like that and would
it would it even hold up in court thank
you thank you for the question I I don't
I don't think there would be a lawsuit I
think that that these settlements that
the the the the receipt of the
settlements is contingent upon the AG's
office certifying that the that the
monies are used for the purposes for
which opota baitman is set out for and
and again to to try I maybe it's too
fine of a point and I'm not doing it
well but to but my point is this
language may be fine as it is as long as
it's clear that in that increasing
access uh to to certain care does not
include providing opioids I mean all the
rest of it is fine I don't have any
objection to the language except that is
ambiguous and we need to be very clear
that that we could not we could not use
it to to provide opioids to people who
needed it that would be completely
contrary to the purposes of the statute
so what what would happen is that that
we we wouldn't be able to certify that
this that these funds were being used
for that if the commission if the
commission saw this if the commission
decided yes we're going to actually do
this and if it was approved by the
governor and executive counsel uh that
that was a a a grant that was awarded
that actually did that then we could be
in a situation where we wouldn't be able
to say to the bankruptcy courts and to
these other settlement administrators
that the money was being used
appropriately and that we could
jeopardize future receipts of this $300
million
okay all right I think we're well set
thank you attorney buetti you're
welcome okay no one else has signed up
to speak on this bill so I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
1318 and open the public hearing on
House Bill
1393 and recognize the prime sponsor
representative
Murphy
good morning good morning good morning
chairman hunt and members of the
committee uh oh excuse
me chairman hunt close enough that's
right he's a lot better Donald yeah that
was yesterday a little shorter though um
I'm Nancy Murphy mayor m uh
representative Hillsboro number
12 HB
1393 relative to the inclusion of
pediatric cancer in the State Health
Improvement plan was filed at the
request of a former
constituent Amy menz found herself in a
situation um no parent ever wants to
experience her young son Max was
unexpectedly diagnosed with cancer here
in New Hampshire and quickly transported
to Boston for treatment following Max
diagnosis Amy became an informed
advocate for Children and Families
impacted by Childhood Cancer Max is now
14 and sitting here today um and like so
many other pediatric cancer survivors is
living with the negative Health impacts
known to be
associated with the treatment required
to save his life he and Amy are here to
to present um their story and how hb19
uh excuse me 1393 will benefit Children
and Families like theirs
we know that cancer is the number one
cause of death by disease in children
and that a double pediatric cancer
cluster was was discovered in the Sea
Coast New Hampshire was noted to be
number one in the nation for Pediatric
cancer incidents in a report published a
few years back we also know that though
there may be other causes cancer can be
an environmentally triggered chronic
disease some of our most vulnerable
citizens our children have been likely
put at exposure
to environmental toxins like PS and
other things in our community in our air
drinking water and soil Childhood Cancer
in New Hampshire certainly deserves our
attention despite the aforementioned New
Hampshire does not reference Childhood
Cancer in our state cancer action plan
when she discovered this Amy reached out
to ask what we could do to change that
HB 393 will amend RSA 126 a87 the State
Health Improvement plan to ensure a more
comprehensive understanding of the
issues experienced by those impacted by
pediatric cancer and make Childhood
Cancer a priority identified for action
in the State Health Improvement plan um
I ask for your support and vote of OTP
um and I know uh Amy will will share her
her testimony and I know uh the
department here is is here to to speak
to how this would uh would work with the
the cancer plan and the the um State
Health Improvement plan thank you thank
you any
questions I'm seeing none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Amy
Mendes I'm
sorry I put a card in okay you to go
okay mondy Thomas yes
okay thank you uh Mr Mr chair and
members of the committee I'm Wendy
Thomas and I represent the town of
marac our local vets in Southern New
Hampshire have recognized that our marac
small animals cats and dogs are getting
cancers I can usually guess where a dog
lives based on their cancer one vet told
me our pets are getting cancer because
they are the canaries in the coal mine
environmental toxins are affect ing or
disproportionately affecting those with
small body weights and people are
starting to notice we know that our pets
are
dying you know who else are our canaries
children New Hampshire New Hampshire has
the highest rate of pediatric cancer in
the United States New Hampshire the
state of lakes and mountains and yet we
are not collecting or classifying
important health information
this bill corrects that so that we can
start identifying and address potential
cancer pockets in New Hampshire thank
you thank
you U you taking questions sure
representative
palazov thank you for your testimony uh
do you have any specific numbers of of
the rate of pediatric cancer in New
Hampshire and is there any like trend on
for increase of it in the last uh years
do I have any numbers yeah yeah yeah yes
no that's the problem we don't have the
numbers this bill would correct that so
we can start collecting those
numbers thank
you other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you okay and I previously called Emy
Mendes there anyy
here
hi good afternoon thank you so much for
allowing me to speak today um my name is
Amy Mendes this is my son Max um I am a
lifelong resident of New Hampshire I am
a wife and a nurse but most importantly
I am a mom um I'm here today to
represent all the moms and dads um that
have heard the devastating words that
their child has cancer I first heard
those words back in
2016 when Max was only six years old and
was diagnosed with acute lymphoblastic
leukemia um we are incredibly fortunate
to have been treated down in Boston at
Boston Children's Hospital in Dana
Farber um max was successfully in his
14th month of Chemo when we were
devastated to find out that he had
relapsed um he then went on to endure
another 20 months of treatment including
both chemotherapy and cranial
radiation um and two weeks before his
scheduled end of treatment we found out
that he had relapsed
again this is where Boston comes into
real importance because at this time
they were offering treatment um that New
Hampshire was not so max was the 12
patient to receive ctis Cell Therapy
which is a new
immunotherapy I see a head
shaking um he then received more
chemotherapy and full body radiation uh
before his bone marrow transplant in
January of 2020 and I am happy to say
that Max just celebrated his fourth year
in
remission I can sit here and rattle off
um all the specifics of Max's cancer
treatment but but I will never actually
be able to articulate um what it is
actually like to sit next to a child
while they go through cancer um it's
absolutely soul
crushing as a parent your job is
supposed to protect your child from
cancer or protect your child but you
can't protect your child from cancer um
we don't know what is causing this in
children um but we do know that the
statistics say that 47 kids in the US a
day will be diagnosed today today and
tomorrow and the next and we know that
Childhood Cancer Remains the leading
cause of death by disease for our
nation's children under the age of 15
years I know Nancy had already mentioned
that um knowing that Childhood Cancer is
not going anywhere anytime soon this is
where we can step up and at least arm
families and health care providers with
the best tools and resources to assist
them and this is where the state cancer
action plan comes into
play adult care is very much centered
around prevention and education and
early detection through screenings and
Pediatrics is completely different um we
need to educate healthcare workers we
need to educate parents and even school
um resources on the signs and symptoms
of cancer in children I was a nurse for
10 years and I missed all the signs that
my son had cancer I took Max to three
different Physicians and they all missed
it too providing these tools could mean
earlier diagnosis in children and
possibly better
outcomes um we need to provide families
with the
resources um on how to access good care
and this is really only available based
on how social workers and case managers
have been um provided the resources
themselves when you get thrown into
pediatric cancer it's absolute chaos and
very much of your day is
lived moment to moment
[Music]
um things that seem easy like a Google
search of what's the best treatment and
what's the best hospital um or a phone
call for assistance or very hard and you
become very overwhelmed and this is why
you really need to support heavily on
these resources in your support
network um families need emotional
supports they need travel and lodging
supports they need advocacy and
financial supports and these are all
tools that could be included
um our family lost a lot when Max was
sick and that is fine I have him here
and I'm willing to lose everything for
that we went from a two income household
to a one income household so that I
could provide care for Max and we stayed
that way for five years um as a result
of that we lost our home and we're
forced to move in with family then the
pandemic hit and my husband lost his job
as as well as our health insurance and
we were forced to rely solely on State
Insurance um as I mentioned earlier Max
received CT cell therapy and that was in
Massachusetts New Hampshire was not
offering that so if that had happened at
the
time that he received that treatment we
would not have been able to receive that
so this is why it's important to allow
families to
access the health care providers that
they deem necessary to treat their
children
um survivorship is a huge Focus
um the average age that an adult is
diagnosed with cancer is 66 the average
age a child is diagnosed is between the
age of six and 10 that leaves a long
time for side effects to pop
up um children are not small adults they
are still developing and cancer
treatment has lifelong health
effects Max is is now 14 he has already
been diagnosed with cataracts growth
hormone insufficiency hyperthyroidism
neuropathy anxiety and depression a tick
disorder bone growth abnormalities and I
could go on um he is at a higher risk
for secondary cancers due to his
treatment and those include other brain
cancer um other blood cancers brain
tumors bone cancer and next year he will
be screened yearly for thyroid
cancer
putting additional supports in place for
Health Care Professionals on how to
screen these children as they continue
to grow into adulthood is important for
these
reasons um another thing that people
don't like to talk about is uh
bereavement supports not every child is
as lucky as Max we know many families
who have unfortunately lost children um
and it's nothing anyone likes to discuss
but we need to normalize this and put
the supports in place um to address
these family specific
needs thank thank you so much are you
taking questions or sure anyone have any
questions guess oh representative n not
really a question I just wanted to thank
you and Max for coming to talk thank you
so much it's not easy to stare down this
group of I hope I made sense people you
did thank you I wish you the best of
help also representative Leon um thank
you Mr chairman thank you for sharing
this and I'm so glad that you are Boston
children and Dana farmer which is a
place to be for Pediatric Al absolutely
so I'm so glad to see you here Max thank
you thank you and representative Bill
King thank you U Mr chairman for the uh
the opportunity to ask a question thank
you for taking the question and I
I as someone who lost a SP house to
cancer I know what you went through um
of course every Cancer is different but
I'm I really appre appreciate your C
courage Max for coming today and and
standing in front of us and hopefully
we're not as intimidating as we look um
I do I do have a question sure
um this bill is mainly to
prioritize pediatric
cancer one of the things I struggle with
uh through losing a wife through through
cancer um is are we doing enough to
actually find out what uh as U
representative Merchant talked about on
another bill what's filling the bathtub
are we are we looking at what's causing
Childhood Cancer is that part of what
this bill is
doing um that I can't answer um enough
like I don't have the information on
that is that something that I would hope
it would work on
absolutely um I think that's something
that the nation struggles with as a
whole is figuring out I mean children
obviously six-year-olds aren't smoking
and they don't work in hazardous work
conditions so it's hard to say exactly
where this is coming from so if it was a
focus um I think that would be
amazing okay thank you thank you
I also sign up to testify is um Whitney
Hammond from the Department of Health
and Human
Services hello chair McDonald and
committee members thank you for taking
time to let me testify my name is
Whitney Hammond and I'm an administrator
in the Bureau of prevention and wellness
and that's in the division of Public
Health Services and that's where the
State Health Improvement plan work is
housed within the Department as well as
the cancer program so this bill really
touches two different programs in the
department um I've provided written
testimony via email so you'll have that
as well uh but I did want to just give a
little bit of context to the State
Health Improvement plan for folks and
then um talk a little bit about
pediatric cancer and I can even respond
to some of the questions about what we
have in terms of data for Pediatric
cancer um so a little bit of background
the State Health Improvement plan was um
something that was passed through
legislation I think back in
2019 and so RSA 126a 88 established it
and administratively attached the State
Health Improvement Council to the
Department of Health and Human Services
and what that means is that the
department is responsible for um
supporting that Council in their work
around both doing a state health
assessment and then using that
assessment to help inform the State
Health Improvement
plan 2019 is when we began the process
of our state health assessment and as
you all can imagine we kind of collided
with the pandemic in 2020 a lot of the
purpose behind the State Health
assessment is to engage community
members to get input and Direction
around what our priorities should be and
unfortunately a lot of people weren't
able to engage with us in the ways they
would have especially people who are
immunal compromised like cancer patients
so um we did our best to try and engage
people using online surveys but it you
know wasn't necessarily the approach we
would have taken in a non-pandemic we
would have had people come and speak to
the council and provide
testimony um as a result of our state
health assessment we did finalize a
state health Improvement plan and that
was released in June of
2023 um it's available on a website New
Hampshire livwell.com
um the framework for that plan is really
about reducing Health disparities in
populations that experience poor health
outcomes and so pediatric cancer is
really an excellent fit for that State
Health Improvement plan um I think we
heard excellent testimony about the sort
of differences between the experience of
cancer as a child and as an adult and I
can just tell you numbers wise in New
Hampshire we have around a 100 cases of
childhood cancers per year compared to
you know something in the closer range
of 20,000 adult cancers and
unfortunately that does lead to sort of
disproportionate focus on adults with
cancer and so this bill really I think
does a great job of focusing on a SM a
population that has a small number but
has some really
significant I would say even trauma
related to the experience of having
cancer and I think you heard you know
Wonderful test testimony about that
experience um I did want to just share
we do have data the the the Department
of Health and Human Services does
collect data on every cancer diagnosed
among residents in New Hampshire and
that includes children um so that's
where I have the information about that
we have around a hundred cases diagnosed
per year and I can speak to the trend in
New Hampshire which has been stable over
time uh so that's available both on our
website and then national uh websites as
well that I believe is everything do do
people have any questions representative
Bill
King thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question um this I'm gonna
ask you In fairness I probably should
not have asked um Mrs mendz this
question so I'll ask it to you since uh
this is uh within your realm uh what are
we doing to find the source of pediatric
cancer yeah so that's an excellent
question so federally there are lots of
you know agencies that are focused on
trying to understand the causes of
different cancers including childhood
cancers that tends to be something that
comes through the national uh Cancer
Institute or NCI so they put out a lot
of funding that goes to researchers who
are usually in academic Comprehensive
Cancer Centers Dartmouth would be an
example of a an entity that probably
works in that field at the health
department we don't tend to get much
funding in terms of trying to understand
the causes of cancer we we really work
more
on known causes of cancer and prevention
so you know a lot of our work we promote
mamography and early screening or
tobacco cessation um we don't tend to be
in the the the space of understanding
causes however I do think that the the
this bill as it's written could
absolutely include development of um a
focus in that area for New Hampshire and
sort of advocating at a national level
as part of the development of that
component in the State Health
Improvement plan and then the final
piece I would share is that the
department did get an appropriation of
$500,000 I think last budget for work in
childhood cancers and we did facilitate
a National Conference talking about
about what is known about the causes of
childhood cancers with a specific focus
on
environmental um
causes thank you representative Shapiro
and then representative
Weber yes thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for taking this question um I
just was perusing the rsas that
involve
um the State Health Improvement plan and
the State Health assessment and State
Health Improvement plan advisory Council
and I
um maybe I'm not looking in the right
place but I didn't see any specific
diagnoses listed or um priority
diagnosis so in that way if we were to
pass this bill would be an outlier that
it would be the only priority listed and
I was wondering if I actually looked at
the state plan which you just um told us
how to find um would we see in there
what were the priorities and um what
were the different categories of illness
um that the plan is
accentuating so great question um it
would be the first specific disease
that's mentioned in that RSA it's
written more broadly about the you know
conducting a state health assessment and
then using that data to guide the State
Health Improvement plan and I think the
Assumption you know with that is that we
would drive our decision-making using
the State Health assessment data and so
for example pediatric cancer might
emerge as a priority in that process I
think what's different here and I was
sitting reflecting during the the the
last build testimony of you know
listening to all of the discussion
around opioids a lot of times in our
state planning processes we tend to
prioritize those issues that are sort of
at the Forefront whether it's in the
news or it has you know large numbers
around it and so sometimes things like
pediatric cancer don't rise to the the
the top of the list so I think the
effort you know around this bill was to
really make sure that pediatric cancer
does get attention in that state health
Improvement plan even if it is a small
number of you know people in New
Hampshire that are impacted by
it follow
up maybe you've already answered this
but um given that this would be the only
priority illness listed in statute do
you have an opinion about whether we
should do that and whether this will
lead to you know one by
one people coming forward and saying
well I think this should be included in
statute so is this is it useful to you
as someone who's really working with
this whole
system yeah it's an excellent question
so I was thinking about that myself in
preparation for coming today and
thinking that you know in a lot of ways
I'm appreciative of this bill for doing
just that because it is giving an
opportunity for um individuals and
policy makers to kind of weigh in and
shape the State Health Improvement plan
in a way that you know I think if if it
if it isn't done in this Avenue they
could just not even you know impact the
State Health Improvement plan that
council is uh a 40ers council and the
representatives on the council were um
named in the legislation and they are in
the legislation it does say that they
are able to invite people to come in and
present as needed to help inform their
decisionmaking but again I think this is
an interesting different approach to
guiding their work um that I would
actually I would be interested to see
other priorities be identified you know
by through this kind of an Avenue for
the State Health Improvement plan
representative
Weber so as as a follow up from that and
and based on what you just said um I
guess my real question is how does the
state plan get revised and is there a
way now that you have been alerted to
this issue to get it into the plan short
of us actually passing this legislation
because although I think talking about
this legislation and this really
important problem is Major and important
I can also see the 47 bills that will be
filed next year when somebody notices
that by coming to the legislature as
opposed to coming to the
council that um their issue suddenly
comes to the Forefront and um we have
seen that in this committee many many
times in many venues and please don't
even get me started on Therapeutics
cannabis
qualifications but is there a mechanism
at the committee level commission level
for the commission members to seek out
more
testimony like this and to ensure that
issues like this then do
get incorporated into the plan
because one separate bill for each
separate condition is a way that lies
Madness yeah um excellent question so
yeah uh I'll answer the first part in
terms of just so June 2023 is when we
released our uh final version of the
State Health Improvement plan and as I
had said that framework is pretty broad
around reducing Health disparities for
populations that experience you know
worse outcomes um part of the reason
that we had such a broad framework was
to enable us to be kind of dynamic
throughout the next 5 years so it's a
5-year State Health Improvement plan and
the intention is that it will be
Revisited and revised throughout that
five-year period um and that's actually
what the council is doing right now is
having a series of presentations from
subject matter experts to kind of review
and refine pieces of the State Health
Improvement plan so I would say yes um
we are set up to be able to make this
kind of a you know addition to the state
health impr Improvement plan as a
council without you know needing a
legislation to be passed um I can't
speak to I it was my understanding that
um there was interest in having this in
statute to ensure that pediatric cancer
was in fact added by the council and
that I can't guar you know I cannot
guarantee that the council would make
that determination you know in and of
themselves representative Palmer and
then representative t
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so if a member of the
council were to say ask for Testimony
about pediatric cancer I'm assuming that
would be something that could be put on
the agenda yes that could be added to
the agenda so as a member of the council
I'd be perfectly happy to do that okay
thank you representative
TZ uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um
M Hammond can you tell
us so so I'm interpreting the desire for
this bill to help increase awareness of
the importance of this particular
condition at this point in time and so
I'm wondering can you please explain to
us are there other places such as wisdom
or whatever it's called now uh where we
can see the incidence of pediatric
cancer and then that's one part and then
the second part
is off times our state plans are more
meant to be aspirational and
Northstar documents as opposed to
actually determining what gets done in
the day-to-day work and can you help us
understand the link
between how your Bureau can actually do
the work whether or not it is written in
any plan you know whether it's this time
or the next three years or in
between great so let me I didn't bring
my pen up to jot down all those points
points but I hopefully we'll get them so
um for those who are not familiar with
it New Hampshire wisdom is the former
name of the Departments uh data
dashboard so it's a public facing
dashboard with a number of different
data points including cancer um so it is
now yeah the New Hampshire data portal
if you Google it it will show up and
there's an entire cancer dashboard on
there where you can see the most current
data we have related to cancer and
cancer rates and cancer mortality in New
hampsh sure there's also um the what do
they call it State cancer profile and
cancer data visualization tools that are
through federal agencies and you can
look at New Hampshire specific data
there as well that's where I go for my
annual percent change data which is what
I looked at to look at the trends of
pediatric cancer in New Hampshire so yes
there's publicly available data on
pediatric cancers it's a little harder
to get it separated out by cancer type
among children um that's something we
could do you know internally as a
department we have that data available
through our New Hampshire State cancer
registry but it's not available on
public dashboards because the numbers
tend to be so small that they have to be
suppressed for privacy
reasons um so that is information about
publicly available data in terms of the
uh State plans in New Hampshire tending
to be aspirational I don't know if you
used Northstar but I've heard that used
a lot too so it's sort of you know a
very general guide of where to head and
I would say the State Health Improvement
plan fits that description and that the
goal is in this next step of the State
Health Improvement plan to start to
flesh out those priority areas and
pediatric cancer would be one where we
can really get specific about what are
we going to do in New Hampshire the
other piece to be aware of is there's a
lot of really good momentum nationally
around childhood C cancer and advocacy
around getting Childhood Cancer added to
State Health Improvement plans and then
you know having them in our state health
Improvement plan can help to roll up to
inform Federal delegates around
policymaking so if it's in New
Hampshire's plan that can be very
beneficial did I miss
anything yeah just uh well so you you
did speak to sort of
uh there is a there is there is uh
there's validity to actually getting
something in the ship I had asked
concretely in the work you do like does
it have to be in the ship for you to be
working on it sort of like the linkage
how strong that linkage is uh for the
cancer program we have some flexibility
to be honest we don't get a lot of
funding that's flexible as I'd said
before we're we're almost 100% federally
funded and we tend to be focused on
adult Cancers and um sort of
evidence-based prevention strategies so
we run a free mamography program we you
know partner on a free coloral screening
program but we don't have a lot of
flexible funding to put towards um the
priorities or you know the strategies
that might be identified under the
Childhood Cancer priority in the ship
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question I
very much enjoyed being on this
commission um um it's
very educational and but one of the
concerns that was just brought was where
does the rubber meet the road and that's
a huge question um with that said one of
my big goals and dreams in life is that
we have between being on this commission
and this setting I've been able to learn
about all the wonderful resources that
we have in this state for all sorts of
things including cancer a relatively
inexpensive way to to do that is to use
what you're doing or this program as
actually informational so that people
can can access these Services they don't
know exist is that part of the theme or
what you guys want to accomplish as well
yeah I think you did a really nice job
of describing the approach in New
Hampshire with the state health
Improvement plan and the fact that we
don't necessarily have a lot of flexible
you know General funds or other funds
available um and so a lot of the intent
behind that uh council is about and
again I said it's a 40 person Council
and then we're talking about right now
how do we get each of those council
members to become champion around the
ship and go out into their local
communities and really talk about what
the priorities are and promote work in
those areas and to your point I mean
there are an enormous amount of
resources actually available and I think
you know in earlier testimony you hear
about sometimes it's very challenging to
actually find those resources or even
like connect them to be able to leverage
and so I think a lot of the benefit of
having Childhood cancer in the ship can
be about that alignment and conect
connecting already existing
resources representative
TZ thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so as a followup can
you speak to the distinction um or
explain how this is a state health
Improvement plan and not a
dphs health Improvement
plan yeah so um I was not involved in
the legislation that established the
State Health Improvement plan but it's
my understanding that it was done with a
a lot of intentionality on making
certain that this was not the division's
or the Department's Health Improvement
plan and that's why it the council was
established and the membership was so
clearly articulated in the um
legislation to include a very broad
membership of 40 people everybody from
transportation to healthc care housing
um and then like I had said uh initially
we the department was only identified as
being admin administratively attached to
the council so that we could be helpful
in facilitating the council meetings and
being able to bring speakers to the
council as you know is requested and we
do that through a contract with the
University of New Hampshire that ends in
June of this year um so it is very
different than our previous State Health
Improvement plan the one that was done
before this was the division's um
Improvement plan and it was very much
Guided by what our federal funding asked
us to do and again this is a lot more
about what do we need here in New
Hampshire and how do we kind of
Patchwork together all those resources
and
partners okay I think we've covered it
pretty well representative plaz last
question uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question so first uh I
wonder if you can send us email help us
to find uh those portals that you talked
about about and maybe if you could like
share with us more detailed cancer type
for children data it would be
appreciated but do you agree with
statement that New Hampshire has the
highest rate of pediatric uh cancer in
the union um so yes I'll be I'd be happy
to send follow-up links to those
different data sources I mentioned and I
would say New England has the highest
rate of pediatric cancer um in the
country we actually um partnered with
Dartmouth and had them do a reanalysis
of pediatric cancer data the finding
that New Hampshire had the highest rate
of pediatric cancer came from a CDC
study Centers for Disease Control and
prevention um and they did not control
for race and ethnicity and we know that
rates of cancer are actually highest
among um white non-hispanic populations
which tend to be higher in the New
England states and so when we did a
reanalysis and controlled for race and
ethnic eity we did find that New England
had higher rates overall but that New
Hampshire was not different
significantly from our neighboring New
England
states thank you very much we appreciate
your testimony today thank you so much
no one else has signed up to speak on
this bill so I am going to close this
public hearing uh that is all we have
until 1 o'clock as far as far as as far
as public hearings are concerned we do
have an executive session um which we're
about a half an hour late on but I'm
going to open the executive session at
this
time and um I don't know if we need a
break before we actually convene or is
everyone ready to go
or
sure you need just Just for information
um am I right in in thinking that we
only have one bill to exec at this point
because we had three that were noticed
and we have more work to do on two of
them exactly um it is my thought that we
would put uh House Bill 1303 and House
Bill 1318 off until February
14th thank you
Charlie because the governor vetoed it
okay will we convene uh as a an
executive committee or an executive
session rather at this time um again
given the amount of testimony on House
Bill 1303 FN and House Bill
1318 we are going to delay Act action on
those until uh February 14th they are
early bills so we do need to um be
cognizant a cognizant of the February
15th deadline uh the only Bill therefore
that we would be considering an
executive session this morning well
actually this afternoon is a house bill
1068 relative to establishing a blood
lead level testing requirement for
children entering daycare in public
schools do I have a motion
representative King did you want to make
a motion
I'd like to make a motion to
itl is there a
second representative Le on seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
representative King yes
um as as good as this
bill or the as good as the intentions
are of this
bill there's there's a missing component
which is how do we actually again back
to what representative Merchant said you
know how do we stop the bathtub from
filling up and how do we turn that water
off uh this bill came up last year was
passed through the house and made it to
the governor and it was it was vetoed at
that point and um I spoke I actually
spoke at the Senate hearing and I
mentioned then that we really need to um
liberate some funds to help homeowners
with bled
abatement um I'm sympathetic to this I
used to be a landlord and I baited all
my
houses but there are landlords out there
that need funds there are homeowners out
there that need funds to alleviate this
problem more testing isn't going to
solve the problem um a checkbox isn't
going to solve this problem and so
therefore I would I would recommend we
itl this bill until next year when we
could actually put a bill together where
there's funding available that's thank
you okay representative Weber and then
representative
Shapiro uh thank you Mr chairman I
actually agree with absolutely
everything that my colleague has said
but I also think that this bill is a
separate and important first step we
passed it once it is the position of the
house I think we should pass it again uh
we have no control as a house over what
happens in other places which I won't
mention but I think for me this bill is
good policy it is a good first step and
then we need to take all the steps that
were also mentioned next year so I will
be voting against itl thank you
representative chapiro yes thank you Mr
chairman um I would just like to respond
to a few of the points um made in favor
of itl
um one is that I would be glad to work
on an amendment that added an
appropriation for lead abatement to this
bill if that's the if that's the problem
um I think that would um be a difficult
sell on a non-budget year but I think
that's a great idea um I I
would first of all I would disagree with
the idea of testing is not going to help
anything because I think it's pretty
clear that when the more testing the
more times that um children are
diagnosed with lead poisoning and it's
not something that nothing can be done
about I mean it can be um there are
medical there are medical procedures
that will help a child if we don't know
that that they are poisoned with lead
and then we find out they are so I think
that um testing is really important um
you know if only to if only captures a
few more people in the state um those
are kids who will not end up with
um other seli down the road um which we
know can be really problematic um and I
would also like to say that
um and I'm remembering so I could be
remembering not quite um correctly but
what I remembered of the governor's veto
message was that this would keep
children out of school that if they came
in if they came into a daycare or they
came into a school and um they were
asked about um lead testing and they
hadn't had it that this would somehow
interfere with um children attending
school and I think when this bill was in
our committee we took a lot of care to
make sure that that was not the case at
all um and I just kind of I wasn't here
when we were talking about this before
but I just briefly read it and it says
clearly that the
responsibility of the entity um where
the child is coming in for daycare or
school would be to give people who had
not had the testing information um not
to Bor them for ad from admission into
that program or school so I would um I
think it's probably as um the
representative said not enough um but I
think it's worthy and I think we should
pass it so I would vote against itl okay
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um I think we learned two
things today that I think are really
really promising um the first is that
the department already has these data so
they already know how many how many many
children are being tested for this and
they already know how many are are
showing that they have unsafe lead
levels um and to me the even better
thing I found out is that some school
districts are already voluntarily
implementing that that means that this
does not need a top down state mandated
solution to this when we already have
school districts who are empowered to do
this if they do want to take on that
task you know right now we have a
snapshot problem we had not only the
pandemic where it was hard to get a
point ments with your primary care
provider but there was also the recall
of these important testing things you
know we see a big glaring red flashing
danger sign right now but those seem to
be those are likely artifacts of that
recall you know right now we are facing
significant issues in child care and
we're trying to make sure that we have
enough child facing people if we add
more administrated burden that just
means that more time much more time away
from taking care of kids and that might
mean that for every facility you might
be one less kid maybe there's somewh
they can handle it but there's others
where this administrative burden is
going to lead to the fact that you know
either you need to hire somebody and
raise prices or most likely you're
trying to allocate those people who can
work at the center and you might be able
to see fewer kids then we're pushing an
unfounded mandate onto our school
districts having them add this we were
told 15 seconds a kid that's great we
have over 3,000 kids in Dairy that's a
not an insignificant amount of time
that's over two weeks of eight hours a
day going through those documents and
looking at it you know I I think that
this is a solution that's trying to deal
with a snapshot in time I think that we
already have the data and local
districts and childcare are already
empowered to do this so I don't I think
that this you know is an unnecessary
overreach representative Murphy thank
you Mr chairman I I I would never argue
you know I I'm sympathetic to the fact
that if you do have this um uh data
reported that it could have consequences
regarding landlords Etc like that but if
I can step back from that as a separate
issue and think about this is only a
healthc care issue the more data we have
and I would beg to argue that I don't
think we have all the data available and
If this is truly as representative
grassy says you're simply adding a check
box or making sure that we note that
people have been tested for lead for
those that come into the state and have
not been tested those have not been
tested here that are not exempt I I
think the more data we have the better
the snapshot and the understanding of
where the problem is and I'm I'm also
thinking about the priority you know for
Pediatric cancer and how we can identify
issues early it's it's it's clear to me
that lead poisoning in children has
significant consequences there are
neurological issues that we all hear
about but there are kidney issues liver
issues cardiovascular issues in my
specialy you know lead and bone will
stay there for 20 years so it is not
like it's in there and you can get rid
of it but also if we do know early on
that there is lead in these children
there are you know we talked about
treatment there are keying agents that
people can take to actually help
mitigate the consequences of increased
lead level so I would never argue you
know against the fact that we would have
potential consequences and I appreciate
that and maybe that's a separate
bill but on the other hand I I honestly
think that this is a bill that gives us
more data and the more data we have the
more children that we will be able to
identify and treat you know
expeditiously so I would vote itl or or
against the itl motion okay thank you
representative TZ uh thank you I just
want to follow on to that that this is
not about uh like a population or a data
issue surveillance happens after the
fact and there's a time delay this is
about having an opportunity that we
don't want to miss to identify and
intervene or offer the families the
opportunity to recognize is that they
maybe can catch something that they
weren't aware of so that the child
doesn't have these potentially very very
serious and damaging uh impacts that are
lifelong and that really affect
everything they affect their ability to
be thriving successful adults oftentimes
contributing to society so we do have
societal impacts and benefit
from uh in you know from trying to help
uh the youths be identified
early thank you
uh representative primmer thank you Mr
chairman um I agree with the healthc
care approach on this and and prevention
is really important I'm going to speak
as a former Schoolboard chairman where
um our special ed costs are a huge
problem and this is one area that the
earlier lead is detected the less likely
these kids are going to need significant
help um in in the district that I was in
at the time the school budget would be
$2 million and all of a sudden there'd
be one kid with an out of placement um
out of District placement and that's
$100,000 5% of the school budget just
poof gone and so I think that aside from
the health being the most important
thing this is a it's it's also a you
know a cost and a and a taxpayer issue
where the earlier we find these things
the better the health is the less likely
we're to incur significant costs that
are born by what my
constituents love to bug me about which
is property taxes thank you
representative
kosman thank you Mr chairman um so
everyone is talking about you know the
health issues and impacts of of lead and
I think we're losing sight of
fundamentally why we're here we all
swore an oath to the Constitution to
uphold that um and to not infringe or
usurp the private rights of our citizens
part one is reserved back to the people
that's the Bill of Rights form of
government all falls under part two um
if you read Worcester versus P Plymouth
which was a court case of New Hampshire
Supreme Court they affirmed um that
government cannot touch those private
rights in part one and Troxel versus
Granville is a US Supreme Court case
that affirms that parenting and um
directing the upbringing of one's
children is one of the oldest private
rights it's one of the oldest Liberty
interests so we can't touch this at all
and I would argue that this law that
requires parents to have children tested
for lead is unconstitutional and is null
and void on its face and we'd be better
off with an amendment to repeal it and
we'd be upholding our oath of if we did
that um to vote in favor of passing this
bill or against killing it is a
violation of our oath um and it's a very
serious
matter because then we are condoning
usurpation of private rights a better
way to go about handling the lead issue
in my opinion is to direct DHHS which is
instituted to help uh the citizens of
this state to raise awareness and
increase education
and Outreach um and
to perhaps uh suggest legislation that
um is directed more at regulating the
practice of medicine and enforcing
what's required of people who
voluntarily contracted with the state
and agreed to be ruled by the
legislature um so we're we're way out in
left field of where we should be uh fun
fundamentally in our our work here
and um we should be focusing more on
Outreach that's representative uh Weber
and then representative
Merchant thank you I just want to say
that I have worked with all of you for a
long time and I know that each one of us
here takes that oath incredibly
seriously clear we don't interpret the
constitution in the same way but what we
have before us is
exactly what was just suggested it is
Outreach it is information and it is
informing parents who may then make a
decision about what they want to do
nothing in this bill requires a parent
to do anything so I think it's
exactly
what my colleague was talking about in
terms of
information but um and I will not go
into the Constitutional analysis of the
underlying bill because it's not before
us today and that would certainly be a
non-gain Amendment which would need a
whole other
hearing representative
Merchant thank you Mr
chair bill is well intended but I think
a couple of things the intent I believe
the bill was to collect data to find out
how successful we are with RSA 130
A5 a b and c we do have testing and so
forth but we don't have any data to help
us understand how successful we've been
doing as far as collecting and getting
levels done so I think I totally support
collecting the data but I think there's
a flaw in the bill fundamentally that I
see and if you go back and look at it
this is what I want to get clarification
on if you go back and look at line
seven and line
eight the form shall include at least
one result of a blood level test
required under the
RSA what happens if that hasn't been
done if it's not done can the child
still go to school so I would ask for
possibly amending it somehow or taking
the time to amend it saying that we want
to have the test done if it hasn't been
done it doesn't mean the child can't go
into school because the form doesn't
have blood level test on it so I think
it's kind of a flaw in the way the bill
was drafted and I think it needs to be
corrected before we move forward so
therefore I'd be open to amending the
bill to get language in the bill to
clarify
that repres we is your hand
up representative Canon yeah go ahead
I'll come back to him having been a
facilitator of of um five Head Start
locations uh and knowing that the Head
Start program requires some sort of
uh um check the box that there the child
that's coming into the Head Start
program has been tested for lead um
that's one of their requirements um but
it's Head Start also caters to lowincome
families so that's that's something that
we need to consider is to H can we help
those families by um providing some
method of getting Leed testing so they
can get their children into the program
um would be important otherwise that
that program which is helping families
and kids um won't be able to service
those those children and the other
challenge is that we ran into at least
in one facility is when a child comes
into the program and does test positive
for lead poisoning is it shuts down a
building for a while so they can
determine whether the lead came from
that building or not um so it's uh just
just to flag it it's an issue not just
for the the family that's has a child
that needs some help um with with lead
poisoning potentially but also could
affect other families who are trying to
get their children educated at the same
time thank you okay representative
Weber I've read the bill again it says
that the forms shall include at least
one result of blood level testing if
it's happened if it doesn't hasn't
happened all the school is going to do
is give the parent information there's
nothing here that says that the child
will be excluded excluded from the
school or anything else so
um without wanting to beat what seems to
me a dead horse more than we have to we
already passed it once it it came out
with a positive recommendation for this
committee once and um there was an
amendment at that time that I think took
care of most of what we were talking
about um and so I see no harm in passing
it again
other discussion representative kosman
thank you Mr chairman I have a a
question it may be rhetorical um but can
anyone in this room point to where in
the second part of the Constitution of
New Hampshire we are granted the
authority to play Nanny and interfere
with the private rights of raising
children by our citizens
I don't think anyone can point to that
Grant and if it's not granted we don't
have that
Authority we can't take anyone's private
rights without a trial by
jury that's that's what our constitution
says
additionally this is a very slippery
slope lead poisoning is not a
communicable
disease um yes it's very concerning
health issue but the best way to get
people to do things that are good for
for them is to show them why it's good
for
them um next will the schools be you
know requiring that they have testing
for HIV before kids come to school will
we direct the schools to uh maintain
arsenic levels of children's blood
because arsenic in Wells is a very
common issue in New Hampshire as well um
cancer screenings you know there's a
whole Litany of things are returning
schools into two Healthcare facilities
because that's not appropriate and we
don't have that Grant in the
Constitution thank you representative
Seth King thank you Mr chair um I have a
different reason why I'm opposed to this
bill um so I have a lot of different
ideas for legislation that I would like
to see you know enacted but I I didn't
file a lot of ideas because quite
frankly I know they have no chance of
passing at least under this current
current makeup we have in the house so I
don't feel like wasting anybody's time
and I don't know with all the respect to
the co-sponsors and sponsor of this
legislation I just feel like unless they
have new information that the governor
has changed his mind or that we've got a
lot more votes in the house and the
Senate to override The veto it just
feels like a waste of time to me we've
got over a thousand bills that we're
dealing with this year and we're we're
going to be rehashing a bill that is
already it's already said and done maybe
next year bring it up when there's a new
house a new Senate and a new governor
and something will have but nothing has
changed so I don't see why we're
spending all this time when there's I
mean look I understand it's an important
issue but I've got important issues too
that I just chose not to not to file a
bill on because I knew there was no
chance it was going to pass and this has
no chance it's going to pass let's just
move on that's that's my attitude
representative
Merchant I would ask the ranking member
to call for a caucus so I can understand
this because I really look at the bill
the way it's written right now if
there's no blood let level test done the
way I read it it doesn't say if it's
been done it has to be recorded it says
it shall be
done and that's my concern is that when
you start looking at this language I'm
just concerned about where it's going to
go and unintended consequences what we
passing thank you it it it
says shall include at least one
result I'm glad to have a caucus if you
want a caucus I will do that um
or we could just take a vote and
everybody could vote the way they want
to vote on the bill
right but would you like a
caucus
Sor I
think
I if if you want a caucus to go and
discuss it we can do that or if you
would like to just vote the way want to
vote that's fine too which would you
prefer I would I would like to talk to
the caucus about am I misunderstanding
this because the way I'm reading it for
btim I see it as being un unattended
consequence and a flaw in it and if I
can be convinced otherwise I'd be voting
for it could we have five minutes sure
thank you and we'll just walk across the
hall Mr chair can I ask for Republican
caucus as well what you want a
republican caucus yeah yeah why
not okay I mean well we're gonna be
unless you're worried unless you're
worried about lunch we we'll will be
definitely be done before that
so
for
I don't do anything as easily as I used
to
okay I think we're all
back uh any other discussion before I
ask clerk to call the
roll I don't see any oh yes
representative mour is not in her seat
oh
okay there she is I'm glad we did not
call the rooll we no it's all
right all right now I think everybody's
back
right I count 20 heads I think we're
good okay all right we'll go to the roll
then I'll ask color Callo representative
Leon yes representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative SS
ORS like bors okay representative Melvin
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour yes
representative
Nagel representative poov yes
representative Weber
no representative McKay no
representative
Fus representative Canon
no representative Nutter upam no
representative Shapiro
no representative Merchant
no representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no Representative
tez no
and represent McDonald
yes 10 to 10 okay I suspect another
motion is forthcoming representative
Weber G whiz I'll make a motion of ought
to pass and I suspect we will have a
similar result but we've been told by
the clerk that we have to do it so I
move ought to pass do I have a second
representative Murphy
seconds any discussion I think we've
already pretty much had our
discussion um so when the clerk is ready
motion is ought to pass on House Bill
1068 representative Leon no
Representative kushman no representative
Bill King no representative kofalt I'm
sorry um representative ORS
no representative Melvin
no representative Seth King no
representative Missour no representative
Nagel Representative pza no
representative
Weber yes representative McKay yes
fedus representative Canon yes
representative Nutter
upam representative
Shapiro representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes
representative TZ yes and
representative McDonald
no guess what 10 to
10 okay Mr chair I'll I'll get you I
will email you a report for in favor of
ought to pass um thank you by tomorrow
morning oh excellent thank you
representative King you'll get me a yes
report on itl yes okay that's the only
thing we're going to take up in
executive session as previously
discussed so um we can't do anything
further until 1:00 which time we'll pick
up post Bill
1593 I guess yeah how does that work
with everyone gives us a little more
time I know
so I think with a couple people
testifying elsewhere I think that's a
great
idea
good afternoon everyone and welcome back
to the house committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs uh we
have several bills noticed for this
afternoon and um first up is House Bill
1593 FN and I'd like to recognize
represent representative springham the
uh Prime
sponsor thank you Mr chairman and good
afternoon everybody I hope you had a
wonderful lunch
uh uh
1593 um establishes a developmental
Services Community integration Fund in
the department of the health and human
services to support individuals with
development
disabilities uh uh this is a disability
Community uh requested Bill specifically
it is needed because people with
developmental disabilities have been ex
historically excluded from certain
social interactions employment
opportunities and educational
environments Community integration
including Recreation is a way to ensure
that all people have access to a full
spectrum of social educational and
professional
opportunities these opportunities are
embedded within the existing Community
rather than segregated uh this not only
promotes the well-being of the
individual but also increases the
overall health of the entire
Community uh as written this bill uh
provides for services that are currently
outside of the existing developmental
disability
waivers uh so uh regarding uh so
therefore um would need the need for the
separate fund uh to provide uh access to
these service Services uh does include a
uh an appropriation from the general
fund uh as written I think that you know
the key issues are are uh for this
committee to address uh include uh the
definition of the activities that are
included and whether Community
integration uh is is complete uh enough
for for uh implementation by uh
HHS um rather than discuss uh how
important these Services can be and how
much uh reduction in other services may
come from access to this uh I'm going to
leave it to those members uh many of
whom will testify uh to you uh today uh
uh to kick off this very very important
bill it is a bipartisan bill I thank you
very much for your time uh to consider
uh this this these services and this
fund for these
individuals thank you
questions for representative
Stringham okay I see none thank
you also signed up to speak is Melissa
nth from the uh Department of Health and
Human
Services good afternoon uh Mr chairman
and members of the committee my name is
is Melissa nth I'm an attorney with the
Department of Health and Human Services
um and the department supports the
concept of of this bill um for the
services that is looking to provide but
um does have would like to work with the
sponsor um to provide some additional
language for some areas um we you know
appreciate the opportunity that this
legislation
provides what uh I will highlight just a
couple of the concerns and areas that
the department would like to work on um
for example in this legislation there is
reference to community integration
Services however this could be confusing
because there are Community integration
Services is a category of services
provided for on a couple of the Home and
Community Based Services waivers um so
in working with the sponsor the
department would hope to perhaps uh
retitle the the name of these services
so that there is no conf Fusion for
services that are covered under a
Medicaid waiver and those that are
not the the department because this
would be something uh additional and the
way that this would be funded would be
outside of the way that funding requests
are handled currently because it is not
through a waiver um the department would
need a position to be able to administer
this fund um and so that is something
we'd like to work on the department did
provide a f note worksheet uh but it's
our understanding in working with the
LBA that they have had uh a lot of
fiscal note worksheets that they are
working on and some have not yet caught
up to the bills but you will see uh the
Department's request in that regard
reflected in the fiscal note
worksheet Additionally the department
appreciates that this bill includes rul
making Authority uh however the
department would hope to work with the
sponsors to or the the sponsors in order
to have more clarity in this bill about
what the legislative intent is um the
department does not want to get to the
rulle making stage and uh you work with
those in the advocacy community and
other interested parties um and have
there be perhaps some misunderstandings
about what the legislative intent was
for example the types of services that
should be included um it how requests
are prioritized questions of that nature
so the department would like to see some
additional language put in to the bill
itself so that it can help expedite
rulle making when that stage comes um
and so and given these open questions
the department can't take a bill a
position on the bill as it's written um
but Wants To Be A continuing resource to
this committee to the bill sponsors and
others involved um in working on it and
with that I'd be happy to take any
questions any questions representative
Nel
um I don't know how that dollar figure
was reached in putting in this
legislation um I I'm not sure if the
sponsor might be someone that could be a
better resource for that and my
understanding is that where the money
will come from uh is in this legislation
it would be looking for a general fund
appropriation so that it would be new
new general fund dollars that are not
coming from a current
appropriation other
discussion any other questions seeing
none okay thank
you also signed up to speak is William
Walker uh from families associated with
Gateway Community Services
thank you chairman McDonald McDonald and
members of the committee uh for allowing
me to speak today I'm usually not used
to going so early in the uh in the
testimony uh my name is Will Walker I
live in Hollis uh with my son and my
wife my son is 24 years old has autism
um but here today I'm representing both
myself as well as a group of people that
I lead uh in the gateways Community Serv
area I have a group of about 275 people
that represent families participants and
other people that are interested in our
space uh in my I'm sorry I'm asking you
to support HB 1593 please uh I first
wanted to start today uh why are we here
our law our New Hampshire law RSA 171a
calls calls for this and I quote I have
to read it directly individual and
Family Services based upon full
participation in the community sharing
ordinary places
developing meaningful relationships and
learning things that are useful as well
as enhancing the social and economic
status of persons served all right so we
can call this
inclusion and what we can call not
inclusion inclusion is not clustering
people with disabilities into one home
classroom workspace or social Center
okay so we're here because the recent
Medicaid rulings have determined that
certain items and services that have
been historically funded by Medicaid in
New Hampshire are no longer uh supposed
to be covered and will not be covered in
the future okay so we have families that
were depending upon funding for these
services for inclusion into the
community that have been now um uh have
that money taken away all right so so
their family members are not uh being
included in the community um and so in
general this this is a gap between what
Medicaid provides and what RSA 178 calls
for okay so um what I I want to talk
about the impact of this so this impact
impacts the individuals themselves it
hurts them both in their mental health
because they are now isolated some of
these activities are physical activities
so it can impact the the person's
physical well-being because it's no
longer exercise that they may get but
the other thing that I see here is that
you know without inclusion we segregate
okay and with the segregation whe
whether we do it on purpose or not we
are segregating people by not including
them in society and once we start
segregating people we see all the
negative impact of SE of segregation not
only on the individual but on society
itself and so let's talk about the
growth of our society right if if we
don't include people with disabilities
in our society we segregate them and we
start treating them differently and we
don't appreciate diversity and with
inclusion we start appreciating
diversity we we appreciate that people
are different we help people build
friendships lasting
relationships okay we grow the community
where we support each other we provide a
network of support to help each other
okay with segregation you don't have
that network of support these people
don't exist you don't realize that they
they they are just like you and me uh
they just have different abilities okay
so by um by uh supporting inclusion you
don't just support the person themselves
you actually help Society grow okay so
I'm asking you to please support HB 1593
to help fill the gap between what
Medicaid supports and what law RSA 17A
requires thank you thank you
representative
not sure representative not and we're
having a little trouble hearing you if
you could maybe move the microphone
closer yeah
so and I'll give you because some of
this is is is interesting right because
you may see this is just recreational
fun activity okay and um in some cases
it's the only way the person can get out
of their house it's the only way for
them to leave these might include things
like karate okay it might include
bowling okay and just Lane rental and
shoe rental okay so things like that but
and so to the to the lay person that
doesn't understand the space and doesn't
understand what it means to be isolated
in your home these things seem like oh
just a night out you know just some fun
activity but these are really really
important
activities a representative
I don't know okay I I don't I don't know
the answer okay um I my understanding is
the million dollars is the ask but uh I
think less than that might be
appropriate but I don't know okay I I'm
GNA let somebody else uh speak to those
numbers other
questions seeing no other questions
thank you very much thank you for the
time to speak
today
I've just been reminded that you need to
speak directly in mic into the
microphone not you know it has to be
directly in front of you to be effective
um also signed up to speak is Lisa badan
uh from strategies disability
Equity hi there can everyone hear me
wonderful thank you uh uh chairman
McDonald and members of the committee my
name is Lisa Bodwin I am a resident of
conquered a parent of an adult on the
developmental disability waiver and a
Disability Policy professional I
appreciate this opportunity to share my
perspective on why Community integration
funds are important and consistent with
the granite State's long history of
supporting people with disabilities to
live alongside people without
disabilities as you know know New
Hampshire was the first state in the
nation to close our institution Laconia
State School the passage of RSA 171a
which this bill is seeking to augment
was one of America's earliest state
level legislative efforts to create a
community-based system of supports and
services for people with disabilities it
is how we got uh people out of Laconia
it is the found
which which made closing lonia State
School possible RSA
171a as you've heard
CMS um uh is has sent New Hampshire this
this directive no longer to use funds
this way um CMS is acting in congruently
by denying the direct costs of
community- based activities given that
CMS has strict housing standards which
deny CMS funds to pay for congregate
housing settings the driving force
behind the Medicaid waivers is to
provide alternatives to congregate or
segregated settings toward the goal of
people with disabilities having lives
that look like their peers not yet
impacted by life with a
disability they want people on the DD
waiver to be housed in the middle of
their communities that yet then have
said to us um uh CMS funds can only pay
for therapeutic art classes where only
people with disabilities are doing art
or therapeutic music or therapeutic
horseback riding or therapeutic gyms
this is a segregated setting and it
defies the underlying logic of
cms's vision and goals for life with a
disability uh New Hampshire's RSA 171a
colon 13 was very cleverly
written to contain words like have
abilitation which is about habil like
life social interactions not
Rehabilitation and social treatments not
simply Rehabilitation or medical
services and I have that quote in my
testimony which you will see I won't I
won't read that quote from the tech from
the from the from the law let me add the
intersection of disability and poverty
poverty is too rarely discussed
due to the severity of the workforce
shortage and housing crisis adults on
the DD waiver overwhelmingly live with
their parents which is technically not
the responsibility of these parents on
their careers families with children
with disabilities fall into poverty at
the highest rates of any identified
population due to caring for their
children mothers reduce the number of
hours they work or quit altogether to
stay at home and provide care for their
children with disabilities adults with
disabilities make up approximately 12%
of the United States working age
population however people with
disabilities account for more than half
of those living in long-term
poverty
and I have two other bullet points on
poverty and disability but the data is
clear you'll see it in my testimony New
Hampshire obtains a great deal of free
care for adults with disabilities their
family members literally pay the price
and find themselves often times
financially more insecure during
retirement when compared to families not
yet impacted by disability the data
doesn't lie it makes sense to ensure
that the loved ones of parents who are
continuing to care for their adults with
disabilities can take an art or music
class alongside their neighbors without
disabilities if people with disabilities
are to have robust community-based lives
wherein they have Equitable access to
activities alongside citizens who do not
experience disabilities we have to
provide funds for these social
interactions and relationship building
to do otherwise is to tell people with
disabilities you can only have friends
with people who have disabilities please
stop wrapping up please start wrapping
up your tesy yes people with
disabilities may not be in the prison of
Institutions but they remain inal
prisons this fund is one key to
unlocking the door and it will make New
Hampshire yet again the first state to
fund habilitation thank you thank you
you taking questions or yes are there
any
questions I guess not okay oh I'm sorry
representative
Nel no definitely not yes CMS funds do
not support housing people with
disabilities oh I'm sorry CMS Medicaid
waiver funds do not are not to be spent
on
housing nothing to do with housing
whatsoever but but there are other bills
to try trying to address housing and the
crisis the disability Community is
facing thank you
also signed up to speak is
Forest is Forest
here
okay
ASW of as Fran
for my first part of my last
name um hi dear chairman McDonald and
members of the committee my name is
Forest I am a visitor in the gr
State please support House
Bill
1593 a fund for people of the
developmental disability waiver to
access
recreational as social activities as a
written goal in their
individualized service
agreement last year my DD budget paid
for my membership at the
YMCA this year it did not pay for the
YMCA because of the federal
changes I have a few health customers so
my daughter watchs me to lose weight by
doing strength training and cardio
exercises the YCA is a great place to
work out it is a great place to meet new
people who care about taking care of
themselves there is not a therapeutic
gym only for people with
disabilities if there was it would be a
segregated
place I want and deserve a life where
people with and without
disabilities are doing normal everyday
things together I have the civil and
human right to be around people without
disabilities I do not understand why DD
waiver fuz can only pay for therapeutic
places I experienced a lot of
discrimination from people without
disabilities people speak to me a grown
man in sing song voices all the time
managers presume I can't learn new work
tasks because
stereotypes about life with a disability
spread of falsehood that I'm not a
lifelong learner like other citizens
without
disabilities how can people learn about
the real me if they don't get to know me
in ordinary
life I have to socially engage with all
different kinds of people of all ages
not just paid staff or
therapists this is my right the state of
Nasser should care about breaking down
the barriers that can keep people with
disabilities from having a life that
looks like like everyone else's
life this fun will give me opportunities
to be a
contributing member of my community grow
as a person and build fresh shs with a
diversity of people which are important
to everyone's wellbeing please support
hell w
93 I could take questions thank
you representative
Shapiro well um be because what what I
have said in my
testimony um I
because I have been on the DD waiver fud
for a
while and and um
and this year it didn't happen at the
why
yeah representative
Merchant
you are very
welcome other questions other comments
representative
predus
thank you very
much representative
Weber you Mr chairman because I'm
noticing that u i I used to be a
playground teacher so I can project but
uh I'm here having trouble hearing the
committee and I'm seeing people nodding
their heads so it's not just me losing
my hearing um I know that the
microphones in this room are are more
geared
to transmitting our voices to the public
but I don't normally they also amplify a
bit and I'm wondering if there's a
technical issue I can go and check next
door and see if she she's okay
yeah again she had meent Christina had
mentioned earlier that you do need to
speak directly into the microphone but
that being said they're usually more
sensitive than than they seem to be
right now so by the way everybody can
hear me I hope okay probably don't want
to but you
can okay thank you representative frus
are you all set yeah uh anyone else any
other questions or
comments seeing n thank you for us very
much you're are very
welcome
also signed up to speak today is Karen
Blake good afternoon chairman McDonald
and members of the health and human
services and elderly Affairs committee
my name is Karen Blake and I live in
North Woodstock New Hampshire I'm going
to be testifying today um twofold if you
will first um in my professional
capacity and then second in my um in my
personal capacity and I'll keep it to
two minutes um first of all um I am the
director of Community Partnerships for
Community Crossroads in Atkinson I'm
here today representing um many family
members who could not be here to testify
in support of HB 1593 FN I will be
um giving you their written testimony on
my conclusion of this of uh speaking
today the um you know basically the what
other people have already talked about
is also in the testimony from um from
the people from my community as well uh
where there have been they had these
wonderful programs that they could go
out into the community and not be
segregated um there are there there's
one letter of testimony about a family
that their child has just crossed over
from the um you know from the school to
the adult system and they're not quite
sure what they're going to do um so we
have wonderful testimony from each one
of them now putting on uh putting on my
family hat um I am a family member um we
live in Northwood stock New Hampshire
and while I work for Community
Crossroads I actually live in Northern
Human Services area
um our situation is um is going to be
very similar U my loved one is going to
graduate on time at 18 however we're
looking at what's going to happen and
where is socialization going to happen
in the community once he turns
18 we're not 100% sure um and these
activities where he can be out in the
community with others are very helpful
um oh there it is great thank you um so
one of the things that um that was made
clear in April was that um CMS the
centers for uh Medicare and Medicaid
were no longer going to um to fund these
non-therapeutic Community um activities
however the um New Hampshire um in New
Hampshire they did say that they would
fund someone to go with someone to these
activities and that they would fund you
know Transportation which is wonderful
however if you can go to these things
but you can't get in ins side then
you're just a person looking through the
window and that's not something that we
want to to have happen here in New
Hampshire and uh just a little bit um a
little bit more um you know uh my loved
one is currently um with inhome support
um this bill may or may not have an
effect on that but I'm looking I'm
looking down the road to 18 um and you
know for us in our situation personally
our circumstances have changed
dramatically with the passing of my
husband so things that were things that
we could pay for now we cannot and you
know we're not looking
for a a a huge amount of money we're
looking for some things and some
activities like you know um the previous
speaker was talking about the YMCA where
you can go and you can you know spend
time with your community it's really
important for everyone and that's that's
uh I know you were going to say yeah
time is up my time is up but thank you
all very much and thank you for hearing
this bill today okay any questions
representative
Merchant this may be actually for the
prime sponsor but I want to be help me
understand we're looking for access to
the activity not for modification of the
equipment within the activity is that
what I'm understanding so we're just
trying to be sure the person can get to
the YMCA not asking the YMCA to modify
what they have within their building to
accommodate the disability or I wrong so
I know that there there are going to be
yes there um there are going to be
people who are going to speak after me
who can speak uh a little more
um uh with a little more knowledge about
that but my understanding is it's it's
to pay for the Activity thank you and
yeah okay other questions representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question I'm I'm kind of
intrigued by this CMS
year um so my son is developmentally
disabled um we went to Lakes Region
community service to talk about Services
there we informed that they can no
longer case do case management for him
which was probably the most important
thing that they were doing for him so it
seems to me that what we're talking
about is yet another thing on top of
another thing on top of another thing
and so you're dealing with a lot of
stressors not just one one am I am I
wrong about that um I can't speak to
case management but it's it there are uh
a lot of things that have been made
clear in the last year from CMS what
they will and will not
pay yep other
questions okay see H done thank you all
so
much I'll just bring this up to you yes
yeah thank you thank you oh
sorry
also signed up to speak is Kim
Habib good afternoon good afternoon can
you hear me I can I'm right up there
right I love a
microphone all right let's well take a
deep breath
here thank you chairman McDonald thank
you committee thank you for your time
time and listening to uh us as families
here
um okay
uh we the families are asking to fund
this fiscal note HB 1593 for Community
integration Services I believe the
funding is so important to keep
individuals in the
community doing activities to help
integrate Collective belonging and also
self-confidence let's look at the
meaning of community which translates to
being in local community town or city to
be part of a community is to partake of
an activity outside or inside with other
members outside the family this is the
reason that Laconia state school was
closed due to the separation of of a
population not included in their
Community or
schools let's look at the word
integrative its dictionary meaning not
segregated designated as available to
all Races or
groups in New Hampshire we have fought
for integrated schools in classrooms and
now we are fighting to support
integrated opportunities in our
communities
being in our community and having the
opportunity of doing activities with or
without certified instruction or
therapeutic for all individuals is
essential for an individual's well-being
and to keep costs
reasonable on a personal experience uh
in my daughter's world uh she has
physical
imbalances she has cerebral
pausy uh doing an activity like
bowling candle pin
bowling uh provides a combination of Co
strength balance coordination in
addition to social interaction with
others around her at the bowling alley
she thrives on getting all those pins
down and she welcomes the Applause on
her
accomplishments this may not seem
therapeutic to many but it challenges
her to do a t task outside of
traditionally medically based
therapies the bonuses being out in her
community supporting local businesses
and connecting with people outside her
family or her medical
team does she really need a certified
bowling or a med uh teacher or
instructor no she is uh at her best
doing bowling and why would we want to
is ol at them that they have to have a
specialization in um in in an activity
so we ask the committee to fund this
fiscal note and set aside funds in this
and future budgets so an individual
service agreement can be utilized for
individuals who experience different
abilities I thank you for your time and
um I welcome any questions thank you any
questions
thank you seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak uh Karen and
Joe I believe it's
Hutch okay hatch I'm
sorry just as a reminder to everyone um
we ask the testimony we kept to three
minutes good
afternoon Representatives uh and uh
committee members thank you for the
opportunity to provide testimony
relative to HB 1593 FN uh this is my
daughter Michaela um out in the
community at feline friends in Salem New
Hampshire and this is um who myself and
my husband are advocating for along with
other individuals that experience
disabilities in the state of New
Hampshire um my name is Karen hatch my
husband Joe is here today we reside in
Salem New Hampshire this serves as a
joint testimony by my husband and myself
in support of HB
1593 we are urgently requesting support
of this bill and an emergency
appropriation of funding as a line item
in the area agency or family support
Council budget specifically for
activities being identified as
recreational uh diversional Community
integration services to ensure that
individuals with disabilities can access
and participate in activities in their
community and prevent further
isolation we have a delightful daughter
Michaela right here who participate who
loves to participate in activities in
her Community she experiences multiple
disabilities and medical needs and would
require 247 institutionalized level of
care if she did not reside at home with
us we have worked hard to integrate
Michaela into the community and have
taught her how to use her strengths
Michaela volunteers and is currently
employed part-time at Heavenly Donuts
she realized Ono one uh facilitated
support in all aspects of life to
include participating in her
Community Michaela began receiving what
is now being referred to as Community
integration Services when she accessed
the inhome support
waiver um during that time these
community activities were instrumental
in maintaining her ability to
participate in community activities that
she would not otherwise be able to
participate in due to the nature of her
disabilities initially the activities
were reimbursed under the waiver BDS
recently alerted families that
activities in the community were now
being interpreted as recreational and
diversional and that CMS would no longer
fund the cost of these activities under
the waivers it's important to note that
um the federal government provides a 50%
match to the state funding that's um
applied to the to wavered Services BDS
indicated that these activities could be
funded via the area agency Family
Support councils however no additional
funds were allocated to the area
agencies or the councils by BDS to
address this long-term need DHHS the
bureau H uh the the um department has
indicated that no money was appropriated
for this urgent need in the 2024 2025
budget and um has has uh relayed that it
is important to come to the legislatur
about this issue could could you
curently there appears to be no
mechanism could you start wrapping up
your testimony please excuse me could
could you start wrapping it up
summarizing oh uh there there appears to
be no mechanism in place to um fund
these
activities um they were previously um
covered and they are now no longer
covered the main issue for me as a
parent is that michaa transferred to the
DD way for recently when she turned 21
to go out into the community um there
are little to no day programs available
um so I as a parent had to build and
develop her Day program which
Incorporated Community integration
activities into her day however because
of this new ruling they are uh not
funded under the waivers and so um it if
uh they are not funded it's going to
result in um not families not being able
to partner with the state to continue to
do this for Lifetime it's not it's not
something that is a year thing my
daughter my daughter's disabilities are
not going to change they're going to be
with her for her lifetime um so thank
you are you willing to take questions
ma'am are you willing to take questions
from the committee uh uh I'm sorry I'm
not hearing you oh are you willing to
take any questions oh sure I'm willing
to any questions from anyone on the
committee
questions okay I think we're all set
ma'am I think I think we understand do
you have any written testimony you want
to submit or well I I I I would like to
say just a couple of extra things please
please be brief we have New Hampshire
has a long standing of being a front
runner and in in establishing a service
delivery system that supports community
living under RSA
171a and
um I I am hopeful that we can continue
to do to do so and um asking this
committee to please um request an
emergency appropriation of funding as a
line item in the area a agencies or
family support Council budget to um
allow for these activities um along with
supporting this um most important bill
okay great thank you very much
appreciate
it also signed up to speak is Margaretta
buala
good afternoon good afternoon and again
you have three minutes ma'am thank thank
you Mr chairman and committee members my
name is Margaretta buala from Dunbarton
and I have a daughter
with I am here in support of hb1 1593
which as I understand uh would establish
a fund to help individuals with special
needs integrate into the community at
large recently the Medicaid program
which distributes The Adult Services
budgets has stopped reimbursing
individuals for some recreational
activities uh including gym membership
and I'm probably not saying anything
that you don't know
already um my daughter has a gym
membership which she takes advantage of
two to three time two to at least two
times a week it is a typical gym where
the general public can go she is
integrated in the community and is a
regular attendee at a regular Zumba
class and she loves this
immensely she is also part of a unified
cheer team which is very important to
her last year her Medicaid budget helped
to pay for that and this year it did
not um interestingly a couple of years
ago the medic Medicaid increased the
allowable budget for recreational
purposes only to eliminate the many of
those allowable
activities my understanding is that
Community involvement is part of the
requirement by Medicaid for individuals
with developmental
disabilities one great way to make this
happen is to allow for recreational
activities such as me gym
memberships many people in the special
needs commun Community benefit greatly
from physical activity and people in the
commun community benefit greatly from
getting to know people with special
needs as a result of the funding being
dropped for these two activities that
she does the burden now falls on the
families
or it doesn't happen at
all and that's the end of my testimony I
will take questions if you have any okay
thank you any
questions thank you seeing no questions
thank you very
much okay and then the last person who
has signed up to testify I I I will
confess I can't make out the name
they're from wolfboro
though um looks like CC maybe Dr a
Carrie Carrie okay Durant okay Carrie
Durant last name is D A and D yes like
no not no D like the band Duran Duran
okay yes and a c a r r IE thr name yes
the clerk needs to have it in the of
course thank you so much well good
afternoon representative McDonald and
members of the committee thank you so
much for the opportunity to be here
today um I wear a couple of hats I am
the legislative liaison for Lakes Region
Community Services but I and shout out
to Lakes Region for yes um and I'm also
a mom and that's the hat that I'm
wearing today um I do live in wolfboro
and I'm a single mom of three girls I
have 17-year-old twin girls who were
applying to college and all of that this
year and I have a 12-year-old daughter
uh who is born with Down Syndrome and I
just wanted to share with you her
photo this is Katie and um she was going
to be here with us today but thankfully
we found an activity for her to do uh
after school so she was able to do that
uh I wanted to share with you our
personal story with um the challenges
with no longer having the funds to pay
for the recreational activities Katie is
on the inhome support waiver
and last year I signed her up to do
dance an Adaptive dance class in
Rochester and along with that a drama
class with her typical developing peers
I live in wolfboro you might ask why are
you traveling to Rochester well it's a
very rural area and there's just not a
lot of activities available um so right
before the uh big recital I got word
from my area agency well we can't can't
pay your bill anymore uh for Studio for
Katie's dance lessons because that's no
longer covered and actually correction
they were able to pay for the dance
because it was uh signified as adaptive
but her drama program they would no
longer pay for so being a single mom
being a lowincome single mom who works
part-time and is the primary carer of my
daughter I had to scramble to try to
find those funds so Katie could
participate in the play
because she wasn't going to be allowed
to participate if I didn't pay the bill
so I had to come up with those means and
now this year I didn't sign Katie up for
and those classes that she wanted to
take the drama class because I'm not
able to afford to pay for them and I'm
really concerned going forward she's
going to be 13 um actually going on 30
um in her mind she's getting her first
phone she's very excited mom not so much
um but I'm trying to think ahead what's
going to happen for her uh going forward
with Recreation and being in the
community she's so outgoing and yes
being in an Adaptive program can be
helpful for her to have that extra bit
of support but she needs to be with her
peers and I'm really sad that um we were
not able to do that this year and the
challenge at her middle school is they
don't have enough support staff for
Katie to participate in after school
programs so that's why she's not
involved um I know my time I heard the
buzzer and I just wanted to say thank
you so much for the opportunity today
and I really hope that you will consider
uh a yes on 1593 and I'm open to any
questions you might have okay right
thank you our representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question I just have a
question about need-based scholarships
to these programs things like that um do
they have anything like that that they
offer that are separate from CMS funding
and things like that so are you meaning
from the area agency I'm talking about
from the program she was involved
directly so the dance studio that she
was involved it's it's not a a it's just
a private dance studio so they did not
have scholarships available thank you
you're
welcome other
questions great no okay I'm saying thank
you so much thank you very
much
was that the last uh uh if you fill out
a pink card for us I can yes I can
answer uh representative Nagel's
question about the million dollars I
don't think I don't think that's been
addressed uh just real quick Alex kbis
I'm here representing the area agencies
the million dollars in the bill was just
a
placeholder um because of the deadlines
with uh OS since that time the area
agencies did a survey five of the 10
responded and prior to the new
interpretation from
CMS those five area agencies were
spending between $40,000 and $50,000 a
year on these services so if you
extrapolate that out to the
10 probably a half a million dollars
would would do it U the other point is
uh as HHS had presented we have to we
have to write rules for the eligibility
to make sure that these funds are
responsibly used and that's probably
going to take at least six months so if
you look at this
bium I would be surprised if even a
quarter million dollars is expended U by
the end of this bium so I I think the
appropriation can be probably
significantly reduced uh from the
million dollars that's currently in the
bill but that's obviously something that
I assume the finance committee would
would look at as this bill will go to
finance but that that the million
dollars was just a placeholder and as I
said if I don't I was not able I made a
phone call um to tr and try to get a
number of folks I think you would also
ask what was the census I did not ask
that question I think I can get that
information far you but I might need a
week or so so I I don't know how many
people had recreation in their budgets
prior to um the CMS the new CMS uh
decree okay did you have a where it was
directed to representative Nagel and
then representative Weber my
understanding based on the earlier
testimonies this bill is going to be
amended anyways would they amend the
dollar amount as well that would be up
to you I would think Mr chairman
uh we would we would not oppose reducing
the appropriation because I I I don't
think a million would would be required
at this point thanks representative
Weber was I understanding correctly that
the 40 to 50,000 was each or in the
aggregate each so that those were from
five area agen okay so we would double
we would multiply by 10 for that that
was that was for absolutely and and am I
would you believe that I'm really
relieved that we deal more with the
health policy involved in this and then
leave this to the cheerful mercies of
the finance committee and I note that it
was the bill was submitted on a
bipartisan basis by members of the
finance committee so I I would believe
that representative
Weber representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair um this is
more towards the policy than the finance
but once it does get through Finance
hopefully with some money attached to it
any thoughts on how the money should be
allocated should be done on a per capita
basis done by individual Grant process I
mean that's more of a poliy decision
than really a finance one but give me
thoughts we're certainly open to any
guard rails that are appropriate uh for
example one of the things that's been um
discussed is should should a licensed
therapist or physician have to uh back
up these type of requests you know that
could be something we could look at we
could look because it's state doar we we
don't have to worry about any Medicaid
rues so we can create the program
basically any way that we we so Des
desire as a state so we're absolutely
open to more guard rules the bill as
written I do agree with Melissa from HHS
uh it's very broad right now and it
leaves a lot of the decision making to
the um to the department through Ru
making but certainly we can bring
forward some ideas to to put some guard
rails on the funds if that would be
helpful follow up thank you Mr chair
today with CMS what is the process do
they require a licensed provider to sign
up on something is this basically
something that I don't want to re create
more bureaucracy here but right well and
and right and when we were writing the
Bill that was I I think for most things
you probably would need a licensed uh
recommendation to be covered Medicaid
has a lot of different rules and and I
definitely agree with uh representative
Nagel that CMS has caused a lot of
disruption in in the DD Community as as
many of you know in the past couple of
years and this is just another another
situation where we're having to deal
with that um so yeah it was a balance
you know we we wanted to get the bill uh
submitted and certainly um I'm not
necessarily advocating that that a
licensed professional has to recommend a
service or an item but but it is
something that we have discussed and you
know it may or may not be reasonable for
some for some
individuals representative Nel I'm
really struggling oh thank you Mr
chairman um thank you for taking my
question I I'm really struggling with
the whole licensed professional thing
because I I really do understand in
certain circumstances it makes sense I'm
not sure that in this circumstance it
does we have all sorts of precedents in
health care for Health Care memberships
and things like that which this seems
this to me to be analogus but my
question is like what percentage of
activities of these PE that adults and
children involved in that actually
require they're using a licensed person
now it sounds like a lot of them they're
not I I I would agree the probably a lot
of them are not it it it would be
another hoop for folks to jump through
but at the same time I think we want to
make sure that the funds are used
responsibly and um we right now I feel
this is a fairly modest investment you
know 40 to 50,000 per area agency each
Area Agency serves you know maybe a, to
1500 people so again I will try to find
out exactly in terms of folks on the
waiver and then if you add you know the
children it's it's even more than that
so systemwide it's probably close to
13,000 individuals but not not all of
those folks are are on Medicaid so
um I I think we need to have a
discussion in terms of the guard rails
that was just a suggestion that was that
was floated out there there there could
be other other ideas that we could look
at in terms of um making sure that the
funds are used responsibly okay other
questions I don't see any all set don't
forget the pink card please absolutely I
won't thank you no no one else has
signed up to testify on House Bill 1593
FN does anyone else wish to
testify seeing no one I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 1593 FN
and open the public hearing on HB 1520
FNA and recognize from our committee uh
representative Joseph
Shapiro
interested in the pinks take one's that
don't those
pinks want two sure where' you get
those oh no no that's
okay
oh oh
okay okay are these copies for everyone
or yeah okay
thank
you okay
great oh thank you very
much okay great thank
you you
too
hey good afternoon representative
Shapiro although we've been talking to
you all day we we seeing you from a
different position this
time thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee members
um that will be this will be a hard act
to follow um this an
impressive um display of advocacy
happening so I'm here today to introduce
House Bill 1520
1520 to you um a bill that will
establish a family assistance car
ownership pilot program in the
Department of Health and Human Services
and I'm going to walk through a little
bit about how I came to have this idea
for this
bill
um in our committee it seems to me that
we are frequently having um discussions
about public benefits mostly Medicaid in
this in this committee but about public
benefits and to what degree public
benefits create
Health resiliency selfs efficiency and
to what degree they
create dependence and de incentivize
people to go on with their lives and um
so this is an issue that I've thought
about a lot since I've been on this
committee um
and this is the this is my journey to
try to solve a small part of that
problem because I think both are true um
for some of us we probably think it's um
Medicaid for ex existent for example um
mostly creates health and resiliency for
some of us are more concerned about the
fact that it might keep people from
moving on getting a full-time job Etc
because they would lose their benefits
so um respecting that both are true to
some extent
I'm I started off looking about looking
for what are the systemic obstacles that
keep people stuck with public benefits
and that for people who haven't
um explored this that is referred to as
the um benefits Cliff effects and um the
probably the most obvious example is a
family is on Medicaid a parent is
working they're offered a higher paying
job or they work offered more hours at
their job but they know that if they
accept those hours and make more money
that they will lose their Medicaid and
they will have taken one step forward
and 10 steps backwards so there are
systemic problems that keep people stuck
on benefits so I was looking for um what
can we do to solve those problems and
much to my surprise I found out as a
benefits Cliff effect group working
group within DHHS that has been um was
was put into statue by hb4 in
2019 and meet regularly and you can go
on the DHHS website and look at the work
that they've been doing and look at
various pilot projects that they've
created to try to mitigate these effects
and help people move forward with their
lives and i' recommend that everyone do
that it's really kind of so Central to
what this committee is about um and I
can give people myself somebody from D
DHHS can give somebody the give people
the link to go and and read about
that
um one of the obstacles that was defined
but there's not currently a pilot
project happening with is a problem with
Transportation
so um it was identified that especially
people on
tanif temporary assistance for needy
families cash assistance welfare um
that in order to work in order to work
at a decent job in order to also like
take care of your family um
transportation is a real problem um
public transportation in New Hampshire
is not sufficient and being a rural
State um pretty much need a car to to do
this so I was trying to help someone in
my neighborhood Who who
um for the last two years has been
working as a
um a maintenance person at chesher
Medical Center so he works the night
shift um doing custodial work
and he has been riding his bike to
chesher Medical Center about 2 miles
from his home um every night at 10:00 to
get to work and every morning at 6: a.m.
to get home and um that's summer fall
spring and winter um so a bunch of us in
our neighborhood were trying to help um
this fellow figure out how he could get
a car drives he has a license I'm very
capable driver but he just didn't he you
know supporting his family he's got
children he wasn't able to save enough
money to buy a decent
car so um in the process of trying to
help him someone came to me and said
well have you tried good news garage
there are an organization that helps
people get cars and what I found out
when I looked into it is that the state
of New Hampshire Department of Health
and Human Services the vision of
economic stability in DHHS used to have
a contract with good news garage where
they got car donations they um fixed
cars up and they either um gave them to
people or gave them to people there's
somebody here from that organization who
could talk about the specifics but they
help people acquire cars either with a
contribution or not I'm not sure um
however that in
2017 that program which um DHHS had had
a contract with for 15 years um was
discontinued um I'm not really sure why
um and since that time good news garage
takes donations of cars in Massachusetts
Vermont and New Hampshire but only gives
cars away in Vermont and
Massachusetts so this bill House Bill
1520 is really an attempt to bring back
that program for people on
tanif um and to bring it back as a small
pilot project at first
because after doing research and talking
to people who are doing this kind of
work um and and probably all of you know
that the prices of cars have really
um have been terribly inflated and
also things being what they are people
are less likely to get you get rid of a
a quality used car so what used to be
the situation in terms of people
donating the cars is much more
challenging now and I'll let somebody
else talk about that who knows more
about that so we decided not to bring
this back as a full-fledged program but
we decided to bring it back as a pil a
small pilot program um to see if we
could get this going and to
um to show success before we try to make
it a more full-fledged larger program I
think in the in the last fiscal year
that good news garage the F fiscal year
um when that contract between good news
garage and DHHS was in place there were
100 cars given to people on
TANF and we're not we're not looking to
do that at all we're looking for a much
smaller program and I was encouraged by
um the people in division of economic
stability to um make it a small program
but also in terms of writing the bill to
make it purposefully vague so that they
could work with a certain amount of
money to get cars based on the current
cost of cars and ensure that those were
quality cars that were not going to like
break down the moment that people got
them um and also to ensure that the
people who got them were able to keep
them up and the people who got them were
able to
um you know to to to to meet some of the
criteria for um future success in terms
of
employability so I did pass out the
state of New Hampshire Department of
Health and Human Services Bureau of
improvement and Integrity Financial
Compliance Unit review um I don't really
know what that is but somebody in DHHS
did a review and I've passed that out to
people and it really talks about the
program that existed for 15 years within
the department um and good news garage
um and talks about some of the
statistics about the effectiveness and
um you can read it yourself really but
um it it does talk about the fact that
in the last year 100 car 100 clients
received
automobiles um that over the 15 years of
the program it was estimated that you
know approximately $1.3 million would
have been saved in cash assistance and
in um snap
payments it also talked about that in
one of the particular years um 63% of
the car recipients closed their tanif
case within five months and there was a
particularly low comparatively low level
of recidivism with people going back on
TANF for people who had received these
cars
um so you have that and you can look at
that
um one one thing that I didn't say when
I talked about the actual bill which
asks for appropriation of um
$220,000 to start this program is that
while good news garage um is here and is
going to testify about their experience
in the past um this kind of program is
not this kind of Bill is not written for
good news garage this bill is written so
that um people within the Department of
Health and Human Services would create
the program and this would be put out to
bid for people to provide um the
Automobiles and the
um the servicing of those Automobiles
and
um the the whole program essentially
would be put out to bid with DHHS um
setting the criteria for who got these
automobiles
so if you're interested in resilience
and self-sufficiency and if you're
interested in people going off um
Federal benefits and state benefits I
hope you will agree with me that this is
a good idea and um vote to support this
bill and I'm very willing to take
questions okay representative Murphy
thank Mr chairman and thank you taking
my question so I just want to be clear
so this is an ownership program they own
the car they are responsible for service
of the car maintenance of the car they
could even potentially then sell the car
down the road when it get to be you know
a bit more of a vintage age is that
correct yes that is correct I I think
you should ask that question also to the
um people from the um from DHS DHHS who
would actually run the program and um
and you could also ask that question of
people from Good News garage who who ran
a similar program with the state
obviously there would be a problem if
people just turned around and sold the
car for a profit and um we certainly
wouldn't want that that would be counter
to the I whole idea um and um I imagine
that that would be built into the
program other questions representative
Nel thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I'm involved in a
lot of committees where transportation
is a huge issue and I'm just wanted to
make sure I understood this is for
employment only right or because for
example um on the opio abatement
commission one of our big issues is how
to people get to inform Services
especially in the North country and we
were working on Transportation solutions
for that could this be used for that or
is it just
employment
two things one is that
um people within
the division of economic stability would
actually create the rules for the
program um and develop the criteria for
who was going to get cars this is
obviously not a thing where everyone
gets a car um you just have to be on
tanif and you get a car um so um people
within DHHS would set the criteria and
write those rules um in my mind this is
a major element is
employability and that this should be
aimed at
people
achieving employment or improved
employment so they can actually go off
of these benefits but clearly um it
would also it is also necessary and very
useful for people to be able to get to
Medical appointments for people to take
care of their kids for people to get to
school meetings and these are all the
kinds of things that are really
challenging for people who don't have
transportation and don't have money to
um obtain
Transportation so it's not a it's not a
one or the other um but it's mainly in
my mind directed at um
employment representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also so
thank you for taking the question
representative
Sparrow first of all I want to commend
you because in our neck of the woods up
here in Sullivan County where I reside
uh transportation in the rural part of
New Hampshire is extremely challenging
um it's one of the major reasons why
people can't get to medical appointments
are work as well so I want to say thank
you for introducing the bill a couple of
questions on the bill on the fiscal note
on line on page I know it's page three
whatever the fiscal note is it talks
about having a pilot program
report submitted by November 1st
2024 given the fact that the bill is
going to become active on July 1 2024
that believe allows about 3 months to
collect data is three months sufficient
to collect data in order to give a full
report about the benefits of it it's not
just a question about the car but also
the benefits of the recipient what they
can do what they have done back before
that's the question to you do you think
that should go to 20 2025 versus 2024
it's on the fiscal note which is next
last page
right well I would say that it would be
that's a very good point um but I would
say that it would be appropriate to be
able to
report what progress they have in
determining what the program is going to
be by then um you know in how you know
and how far they've gotten to setting
criteria and um how far they got in um
Contracting this program with somebody
um but clearly they're not going to have
data on
um the actual program and how successful
it is by
them follow
up thank
you and then the other question I have
is where M with the Department back in
2017 how much state was spending on the
program and why it was discontinued do
you have any information about that I
should leave that for Department of
Health Human
Services
um I do not know why it was discontinued
although obviously you know in a budget
year people go over the budget with a
fine tooth comb and some years are
were're more flush than other years and
sometimes
um you know somebody doesn't like what
they see in the budget or somebody has
another idea for how the budget money in
the budget should be used that um they
think is more important so I don't know
the details on that I will say that in
this review of the program they do say
that there were never any compliance
issues with the program or disputes
within the program and um the department
so I I I don't I don't really know the
answer to that question I do know that
at one point
um the vendor good news garage who was
handling this um and they can talk more
to this um was the amount of money it
took per car per client was um
something lower than
$6,000 and I think when we would when I
was discussing this with Karen Hebert of
um the division of economic stability um
one reason she wanted it WR without too
many specifics is that the cost of cars
has gone up tremendously and the
availability of donated cars has gone
down so they wanted more flexibility to
create a program that would really work
I mean just like we don't want people
selling cars after we give them we also
don't want them to like break down
immediately after after they get cars
thank you Mr chair uh point of
correction uh represent Weber pointed
out to me on page two of the bill it
does say the report will be done by
November 1st of 2024 but then annually
thereafter so thank
you other questions representative
Missour thank you and thank you for
taking my question um I know it's been
Al alluded to several times um before my
question but I am interested if not by
you um by someone from DHHS or good news
garage of of what is in place to prevent
someone from receiving a car and then
immediately selling it so I know you
can't answer that I am too so okay thank
you thank
you other
questions seeing no other questions okay
thank you representative chapero thank
you also signed up to speak is Brian
Clark from the Department of Health and
Human
Services
thank you chair and members of the
committee my name is Brian Clark and I
have with me also Jean panod uh on
behalf of the Department of Health and
Human
Services um so I'm here to testify as to
what this bill would do which is to
create a small pilot program that would
address the single greatest um problem
with people on nhp returning to
work and I'm here to answer any
questions if the committee has
any okay um actually I have one I was in
the department for a long time and I
dealt with the tanif program for a long
time uh but I've all so been retired now
for about almost 5 years so I've forgot
a lot
unfortunately um we're talking about uh
employability uh is one of the reasons
to have a car um is there a tan of work
requirement or job search requirement I
think there was one at one time but I
don't know if there still
is uh yes there is okay yeah okay makes
sense representative
Weber thank you and take thank you for
taking my question I wonder if either of
you could answer the question about when
the prior program existed how did we
ensure that people didn't just sell the
car because clearly that wasn't the case
and I haven't had time to read that
whole document but um I wonder what the
safeguards were to ensure that the car
was used for the intended
purposes so there was no actual
Safeguard when an individual
did receive a vehicle they ultimately
had the ownership of the vehicle the
title registration they were responsible
for all that however what we did do is
we educated individuals on the
importance of maintaining a car in order
for them to remain employed to help with
their family to be sustainable in terms
of getting individuals to doctor's
appointments uh other types of
appointments that would otherwise keep
them recidivating back onto the program
but there was no actual way of ever
prohibiting that now being involved in
the program for many of
years I never heard of one incident
where an individual turned around and
sold the car for profit once they
received it from Good News garage there
was no incidences ever reported but um
so moving forward can we put some
safeguards in place something that we
can take up as a certainly as a
consideration and as a safeguard moving
forward with if in the event These funds
are appropriated for this
purpose what if it wasn't a problem we
don't need to now representative
Canon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question what happens to the
car if um the individual that's been
given to loses their
job they keep the car yeah still their
car um what typically would happen also
if an individual would lose their job
they would come back onto tanif in order
in a way to help support their family
and then we would reh help them
integrate back into finding a new job or
uh appropriately participating in the
nhp program to put them through some
type of education and train training to
get another job okay
yeah thank you representative kosman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here and taking my question um I'm
wondering my husband's a mechanic and we
are used cars car people we've never had
a a new car ever and with used cars come
lots and lots of Maintenance even when
you think that your car is all set my
husband's done the one over the two over
the three over of my vehicle and fixed a
bunch of things and then we bring
inference inspection and all of a sudden
there's a new code that we never thought
was going to be there um so my question
is does the depart is the department
going to have any continuing
responsibility for that car once the
ownership is
transferred and should we put that in
the bill somewhere and make it clear
that they will
not uh it's that's a great question uh I
can tell you in past contracts that
we've had um with good news garage
that there was a
um a a policy in there that helped us
with maintenance requirements to the
vehicles for a certain period of time
and I think at that point it was I
believe in between six or nine months
from when the individual received the
vehicle um though that was written into
our contract that good news garage was
responsible for helping with the
maintenance of vehicles in the event
something happened that was outside of
the control of the owner of the
vehicle um they would um they would be
sure to rectify any issues when uh when
something went wrong we had excellent
relationships with uh good news garage
uh we could certainly make a phone call
on behalf of our participant or the
participant could call thems and say
this went wrong and they'd be like bring
it in we'll we'll look at it we'll
address it and we'll fix
it yeah other
questions see none okay thank you very
much thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Brianna
hankle from new
futures
no you need you needed
yeah I'm glad I asked there you go um my
name's Brianna hle I'm from New Futures
I'm the legal policy fellow at new
Futures we focus on how to improve lives
and wellbeing in New New Hampshire
through policy change um I can't talk
much about the technical questions that
have been coming up but I can talk about
the importance that new future sees in
this program um uh there's only 34
communities in New Hampshire that has
access to public transportation so
especially in the rural areas they can
really struggle um and people in general
when they add additional weeks of work
it go uh their cost of Transportation
goes up by
$200 and so this program would help um
reduce costs and also help people in
rural areas to get to work
um sorry to get brief but is there any
questions or anything any
questions seeing none okay thank you
very
much would you take the
two okay and also signed up to speak is
cash Cranson from um Good News
garage thank you Mr chairman and
representative Shapiro uh my name is
Cash Cranson I'm the vice president of
advancement for centri Care Alliance
which is the um parent organization of
good news garage um I'm here to speak in
capacity for the past four years I've
been the director of operations of good
news garage it's a um program and
organization near and dear to my heart
so I will attempt in two minutes to kind
of talk about the impact that I believe
uh this H this house bill 1520 and a
vendor like good news garage can have on
granite Staters um I've been in health
and human services for for the large
part of my career I also try to address
all the questions that I heard um
succinctly it's outcomes are sometimes
hard to find in Health and Human
Services uh when I took the job at the
head of good news garage four years ago
I loved it because the outcomes were so
concrete um it spoke to both sides of
the political aisle it was such an easy
program to Market and speak about when
you give someone a car when you give
someone a ride you see the difference it
makes in their lives when you give them
a ride time and time again um and I say
give a ride we do operate two program so
we have our car donation program good
news garage also has a transportation
program where where we provide um van
individual or congregate transport um to
folks all over to get to appointments
work um
employment and when you're giving
someone a ride over and over again for
weeks on end so they can keep their job
and you see them move towards more
stability in their life and
self-sufficiency you see the emotional
impact that has on them and it's big
it's huge so i' I've seen it firsthand
and I want to testify to the importance
of that and I believe this bill is a
step in the right direction I live here
in New Hampshire myself um and I would
love to see good news garage or a
version of this bill being in place for
granite sters transportation is a huge
issue um good news garage started about
28 years ago in Burlington Vermont very
Grassroots such as representative
Shapiro mentioned where he was helping
someone in his community um a guy in the
Lutheran Community up in Vermont
realized that people in his congregation
couldn't didn't have the money to fix
their cars and he knew how to fix cars
so he started fixing cars and gain some
traction um we've given over 5,500 cars
to new englanders uh in the past two
decades uh annually we provide about
15,000 rides through our ready to go
program it's serious impact uh and I
think it's really important and I think
it direct uh addresses some of these
Transportation needs head on in terms of
the structure of program um I will
attempt to answer a couple of the
representatives questions quickly here
uh historically good news garage does
provide car ownership uh to the to the
person receiving the car and we think
that's a good thing right because it it
provides dignity it provides that
self-sufficiency that folks want um we
have uh this the program is structured
different ways and different states
depending on our partners right um to
answer representative kushman's question
we do warranty the vehicles in all our
contracts like for instance in Vermont
we warranted them for a year uh the way
that program structured is the
individual will have to come in
quarterly and check in with good news
garage as well as their case manager
through the state um and if they get
their oil change and check the car in
then that's free of charge right and if
anything needs to be fixed we fix it
that's part of the contract that is a GU
I would answer that that's a guard rail
to some of the other Representatives
questions around selling the car because
it's it's basically we're trying to
instill
um that self ownership of the car and
and part of that is the education of how
to take care of your car and of course
so we're going to take care of this for
the first year of you if you do these
steps
um so to I think another question was
asked around the the safeguards you know
historically here in New Hampshire and
as well in Massachusetts and Vermont
there isn't actually a concrete
Safeguard around the titling of the car
so there is nothing to be clear there is
nothing to prevent recipient to go
around and sell that car in my four
years and what I've been able to track
it it echoes um the gentleman's from
DHHS here uh we rarely see it I'm not
going to say never we have seen it once
or twice where someone does lose a job
um or you know uh with the OPI epidemic
they might fall back into addiction
something happens and they've sold that
car but I would say if you know and this
is anecdotal but in 5,500 gives I can
only find a couple in 10 years that were
sold um and I think uh to speak to
representative Shapiro's um comment
about the flexibility that um they want
this Bild to be designed in the program
design additional safeguards could be
put in I think uh our experience with
the state prior and in the other states
that we operate no one really wants to
be the Repo Man right so if we hold the
title that would be the kind of initial
or if the state holds the title right no
no one can sell a car however then we
have to go repo a car um and that can be
maybe not cost effective um maybe add
some bureaucratic onus but there are
some options here in program design to
look at additional safeguards but a lot
of the safeguards do Echo um the
gentleman here from Health and Human
Services where we really want to instill
the Dignity of car ownership and we
incentivize that by staying with the
program for whatever determined amount
of time and you will get your repairs
for free you know you will get your car
warrantied and we will keep you on the
word on the road towards economic
self-sufficiency so in conclusion um I
think the only other thing I wanted to
prepare you know we have lots of data at
good news garage um personal testimonies
we Market them so that we can get
donations from community
members two years ago uh in my personal
life I like Recreation and Athletics I
was at the health club I was playing
basketball I was talking to a friend of
mine and his wife asked what I did for
work and I said oh I run um a local New
England nonprofit when we give cars to
people in need and she said oh good news
garage and I said yeah and she started
uh crying tears of joy and she said
eight years ago you know I was at a low
point in my life I just had my son I'd
lost my job and I got a car from Good
News garage and enabled me to get a new
job and stabilize myself she's happily
married to my friend works at Fidelity
for four years now and she attributed it
to that car starting her life over it
hit me home because I wasn't on the
clock you know um and I think that is
maybe a good story of the power of what
this bill can do for granite Staters
okay any other questions for um this
gentleman a representative kman thank
you um can you describe to us like what
say I come in with a car and I want to
donate it um what the process is for
once it comes in the door and then
um like what you guys do to it you know
how you check it over and everything
yeah absolutely it it differs a little
bit depending on where we operate but in
general you know we get donations from
all over New England we have staff um
who have car backgrounds right and
they'll evaluate that donation on paper
right and a lot of times you know people
donate junk right and so we we basically
go through a screening process to see
what um we think the car is going to be
fixable we will tow a car in or go pick
up a car car depending on geographic
location and evaluate the car uh through
basically a network of mechanics we used
to have brick and mortar garages where
we actually had our own service teams
but um in the years since we've kind of
subcontract that out so to speak so we
have networks of mechanics and you know
if someone in suvin County if we don't
have you know we got to get in there and
so we'll build a relationship with a
garage or or like your husband for
instance right and um we'll have those
folks go through a formal evaluation and
it's theum similar to like a 175 point
inspection it's safety oriented right
but we're also looking hey is this car
you know from a professional opinion we
want to get the maximum efficacy out of
this car ideally two to three years and
you know your question earlier spoke it
right it's used cars some occasionally
there's a lemon but good news garage is
always you know um good for that
partnership and and so there's always a
solution there but we basically evaluate
the car um frame and rust work is
usually the problem that will get most
donations you know if if the frame's
rusty it's not worth putting any money
into um and then we will fix this car up
and award it to a client um and warranty
it uh for whatever the period
is follow up thank you um that was very
and I just am wondering if you get a car
that's um like a rejectable like you
wouldn't pursue fixing it what do you
guys do with it do you junk them all and
have them crushed or do you try to
resell them first no we resell we we are
um we sell at auction um in Vermont
we're actually one of the largest used
car dealers due to our selling cars at
auction and um what's interesting is
that Vermont has a lot of rust right and
so we and it has a very high inspection
standard so the amount of cars that we
can award to um recipients is limited
and so we auction off the stuff that we
can't and um folks will bring that to
places where you know they can get away
with getting the car on the
road I'm representative Seth King thank
you chairman thank you for taking
questions today uh it sounds like you
get a lot of cars donated and then it
sounds like you're also getting some
money from cars that you auction off um
how else do you get your funding are you
getting people that write checks to you
as donations and how much if any of your
uh of your income comes from state or
federal agencies thank you um so good
news garage uh operates primarily on
with income through state and federal
agencies right um we do have auction
Revenue um and because occasionally
right so the way the programs have been
designed we occasionally lose money on
the programs but we offset that with
auction Revenue we have a very small
amount of folks who give cash donations
but it's not insignificant right I'd
have to look I think it's 75 to 90
people across New England um um we our
donor um base is primarily folks who
donate a car they come back a couple
years later their kids off to school
they got a yard they want to donate
another car you know and that's what we
cultivate but we do have some folks um
of higher capacity who have seen the the
impact that we have and support good
news garage through philanthropy as well
follow up thank you for that answer um
you said that you currently are getting
the majority of your income through
state and federal agencies can you um go
into detail a little bit more about that
um for example New Hampshire um aside
from this program which isn't enacted
yet what um what programs are you
currently involved with with the state
of New Hampshire so good news garage is
not in involved with any programs the
state of New Hampshire right now and
that's why I'm here today we've for a
couple years wanted to be um the
challenge is the scarcity of donations
right um since covid and since the Ed
car market has exploded we've had to
work really creatively to continue to
get viable donations that we can award
and give to people safely that remains a
challenge part of when representative
Shapiro was reaching out to us we said
we want to be realistic about that
challenge we said we can't deliver 100
cars to New Hampshire Granite Staters
right now so we need to start small and
as we start small we'd ideally expand
our visibility back in the granite state
again and through that hopefully gain
more donations so that we can award more
cars but no we are not active in New
Hampshire despite our historical
relationship here and you know like I
said I live in Chester that's tough
right we want to we want to be helping
people in New Hampshire
federally uh no so I I might have
misspoke you um we have contracts in the
state of Massachusetts through the
Massachusetts Rehabilitation Commission
and we have contracts in Vermont through
the economic service division which is
similar it's a program of you know DHHS
there um and those are those are State
contracts um every once in a while they
have federal dollars and they have to
figure that out on their end but it's
not it's not for us we have very little
federal reporting thank you other
questions represent presor Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question this may actually be
a question for the Department of Health
Human Services but I notice in the audit
that they did on the financial
compliance it dealt with the issue of
the benefit social benefit to both the
recipient and Society do you know if any
other states have done such an audit
with Good Neighbor Garage and looking at
recipients of receiving a vehicle in a
benefit to them both financi as well as
to the state and what the benefit has
been as far as trying to reduce the
overall benefit cost to the state
because they actually have a
job uh can I is that was that a question
for
me if it's for you or for somebody from
the Department of Health Human Services
I can start and um they can answer you
know so we've actually attempted the
past two years to do that because the
infamous letter you know it's great data
and we said okay we need to replicate
that so we worked with the University of
Vermont and our contract Partners over
in Vermont to try to replicate some of
this data um the project is somewhat
stalemated uh for various reasons um
different priorities uh but we are
trying to kind of look at that in
Vermont specifically Massachusetts has
been harder there's a lot more hippo
compliance around the client base that
we have um and so being able to access
the data has been harder we are trying
to access that data and ver Ma and have
look backs you know internally at good
news garage we do look that we have
outcome surveys and it's another kind of
guard rail to keep folks invested in the
program so we check in with them every
three six months year um postcard give
and say how are you where you at are you
off
benefits um that's self-reporting right
so it's not it's not crosscorrelation of
the data with the Departments and we are
working on that in Vermont but I don't
have actionable data yet thank you other
questions say no other question oh
representative Shapero well actually
yeah I'm sorry you can't testify you you
already testified you can't you can't
question can I just ask you a question
can ask me a question sure um I'm just U
this is not a question um but I really
I'm realizing that one area um that
people have been asking about has not
not been covered so maybe I don't get
another opportunity to um comment on
that but if I could I would I don't
believe you do do you I don't I don't I
don't believe the rules allow that you
can certainly email people
okay see no one else with questions uh
thank you thank
you and no one else has signed up to
testify on this bill so I'm going to
close the public hearing on HB 1520 FNA
and open the public hearing on hb1 1612
FN I don't see representative grassie
here uh is anyone else here to uh
introduce this
bill hb1 1612
FN apparently not
okay all right um no one else is anyone
signed up to testify on
it okay sure okay the chair would
recognize representative uh Lucy Weber
to introduce the bill and if you'll
indulge me I'll do it from my seat um Mr
chairman uh as a courtesy my name is
Lucy Weber I am um representing chesher
12 and I am introducing House Bill 1612
FN relative to requiring the Department
of Health and Human Services to conduct
surveys and assess concentrations of
certain radioactive materials and I
fervently hope no one will ask me any
questions about it because I don't know
anything thank you representative
Weber um signed up to testify is Lou
baronelli from the Department of Health
and Human
Services and Abby roges
also your name's kind of off to the side
there but uh it's on here so
welcome
good afternoon chairman McDonald and
members of the committee my name is Lou
baronelli and I'm the administrator of
the Water Analysis Lab at the New
Hampshire Public Health Laboratories I
want to thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak on House Bill 1612
FN oh good good afternoon I'm Abby
Rogers I'm the legislative liaison for
the division of Public Health Services
and I'm just here um as a resource on
section four of the bill if there are
any
questions at this time the department
does not hold a position on this
legislation I believe you have copies of
Our Testimony and the fiscal note that
describes the funding and resources
required to implement the bill if it is
enacted what I would like to do is
describe for you what the department is
doing relative to radiological
environmental
monitoring uh this program is described
in the state's radiological emergency
response plan under RSA
107b currently the public health lab
monitors for gamma Alpha and beta
radiation throughout New
Hampshire gamma radiation is a harm is
harmful through whole body exposure
where Alpha and beta radiation are
harmful when ingested or
inhaled approximately 800 samples are
analyzed annually for
radioactivity sample types include
particulates in air depositional wipes
surface water sea water marine biot milk
silage animal feed and sediments
we also manage a thermoluminescent
dosimeter TLD
program tlds are devices which measure
direct gamma radiation and air uh these
devices are strategically placed around
the emergency planning zone surrounding
sebr station 40 of these are located
within the 5 and 10 mile radius of the
plant with an additional 22 within the
50 m radius and 15 as control rolls
placed outside the 50m Zone TLD monitors
are collected manually on a quarterly
basis by the the DHHS staff and tested
at the public health laboratory in
conquer d uh data generated by DHHS can
be found in the
nhhs data portal the link is provided in
the written
testimony also the Environmental
Protection Agency currently has two
radnet air stations with real-time
monitoring of gamma radiation located in
the state of New
Hampshire one is located uh at the
division of Public Health Services on 29
Hazen drive and conquered and a second
Air Station was added in the fall of
2018 and is located at the Portsmouth
fire station in Portsmouth New
Hampshire in addition to direct gamma
radiation um analysis air filters from
the radet stations are collected by DH
HS staff and sent to the EPA regul uh
laboratory weekly to test for beta
radiation and epa's website posts the
results and are available to the public
at the EPA radet dashboard that link is
also provided in the written
testimony I just want to mention that a
similar bill was proposed in
2018 and at that time the department
worked closely with the EPA to secure
the deployment of epa's Last radet
Station it's the one located in
Portsmouth uh no additional monitoring
stations will be added or managed by
EPA great thank you uh I'm going to
comment on section four of the bill um
also in the legislation uh the
legislation proposes to allow the
department to allocate State emergency
planning funds to assess air pollutants
uh for the intended purposes of uh
assessments uh to detect any possible
elevated rate of pediatric rabdom
myosarcoma pleuropulmonary blastoma and
brain cancer which are pediatric cancers
in an area extending 10 miles from
Seabrook station nuclear facility the
department assumes the attend of the
legislation uh maybe for the Department
to conduct a cancer concern
investigation following the Department's
protocol if warranted in order to
complete this work the department may
need a uh environmental health
epidemiology position but again we're
unclear on the intent given the
language thank you representative
warber thank you Mr chair and I seem to
have lost all control over my paper work
but was the written testimony handed
out uh the testimony was submitted
submitted electronically oh okay thank
you I'll look for it there
representative notam thank you for
taking my question um you said you test
800 samples what's the time per year per
month not per day uh that that varies
depending on type of samples so uh the
thermoluminescent doers the TLD samples
are collected quarterly okay uh there
are samples that are collected and
analyzed weekly and monthly as well I I
don't know if you want me to go into
detail I'd have to pull no but there
there's I just wanted a a vague idea
thank you for asking the question thank
you representative kosman thank you Mr
chairman are is the department aware of
the nonprofit C10 research and Education
Foundation that conducts surveillance
within 10 radial miles of the cab Brook
plan the department is aware of of C10
okay do you see any redundancy here with
what we're trying to do and what they
already are doing with funding for
Massachusetts uh so we C10 does some
monitoring um I I personally do not know
the extent of which there may be
somebody here that could speak uh to
that uh so again I don't have the
information on that sorry and and and I
think I just add that the the the
monitoring program that the the
department conducts is again described
in RSA uh for our
radiological emergency response
plan okay other questions representative
Nagel you look like a no okay any other
questions
seeing none okay thank you very
much also signed up to speak is Sarah
Abramson good afternoon uh my name is
Sarah Abramson and I am a resident of
stratum New Hampshire and I'm also
executive director of C10 research and
Education Foundation so I might be able
to answer some of your questions um I
did submit my testimony in writing as
well um there are some visual Graphics
at the end that could be
helpful um I want to start off by saying
that my purview and expertise is really
in radiological monitoring of the air uh
this bill is a little broad as I read it
to include liquid and solid forms as
well um and I'm referring just to
section one uh for what my testimony is
relevant
to uh C10 stands for Citizens within the
10 mile radius of the Seabrook uh
nuclear power plant which is the
evacuation pathway emergency planning
zone of that plant um I'm here today in
a professional capacity and also a
personal one I live inside the sebr epz
uh with my husband my four-year-old son
and my kitten I have an educational back
ground in environmental science and
policy and I have an intimate
familiarity with real-time radiological
monitoring of the air uh because C10 has
provided this service under contract
with the state of Massachusetts for over
years um I'd like to start by sharing a
story of particular relevance to this
proposed bill you all may recall on July
12 2022 an evacuation alarm was
inadvertently triggered at C Brook
station and that set off an evacuation
alert across all of New Hampshire's
beaches uh given that it was a hot day
there were thousands of peoples on the
beach and when the alarm was sounded
many people scrambled to their cars to
turn on the radio instructed by the
siren's message to do so um but of
course nobody was talking about an
emergency because there wasn't one it
took almost one hour for CBR station its
owner's next era to craft and deliver a
public message that there was no
emergency uh my cell phone the cell
phones of many of my board members uh
were ringing off the hook with some
frantic people if I'm being honest like
crying mothers wondering if they should
get their kids in the car and evacuate
um and all of that frankly could have
been prevented by better communication
um but also by readily available
radiation information at the state level
or at least a public portal that um
citizens could access on their own to to
get that peace of mind um the skepticism
from the public um not just that day but
also the days that followed is born from
that the lack of uh real-time radiation
monitoring from somebody independent of
the corporation that runs the nuclear
plant um the ability for the State of
New Hampshire to be empowered with that
information um can also enable it to
decisively take action without having to
wait for somebody else some outside
party to provide them with this
information um not just in a real
emergency but as we saw in a false
emergency it can be a public safety
issue to have people uh reacting to a
false
emergency um within minutes of the
activation C10 spoke directly with the
NRC resident inspectors uh we
communicate often and they verified it
was a false alarm due to a technician
error and we immediately shared that
information with our Massachusetts
Department of Health and Massachusetts
Emergency Management agency
partners um we also were able to confirm
with them as an independent body that we
weren't seeing any radiological releases
that indicated anything abnormal was
happening and we continued to provide
that as a public statement both on the
news and on our website and to the state
of Massachusetts in the days that
followed um another relevant story of a
is the nuclear disaster at the Fukushima
daichi reactor in Japan in 2011 I'm not
making any comparisons between CBR
station and that reactor but I simply
want to point to the many
reports um in the years that followed
highlighting how the government um a and
emergency response Personnel were unable
to communicate effectively with the
people that were at the plant because
the earthquake and tsunami that caused
that disaster brought down a lot of
communications infrastructure so
traditional phone and internet and
power uh without that critical
connection uh the plant couldn't receive
instruction from decision makers
decision makers couldn't receive
insights um on the severity of any
radiological releases um and another
unfortunate Discovery was that officials
inadvertently evacuated citizens into
high levels of radiation where wind had
pushed some of the plume um and
something that could have been prevented
had they had a network of realtime
radiological
monitors so for the last 30 years the
state of Massachusetts has contracted
with C10 to provide independent realtime
radiation monitoring uh the data is
accessible to State officials
247365 providing unfettered um access to
keep Public Safety information and that
is through a secure private portal um if
public uh if members of the public do
want information they can submit a
public records
request um we're able to provide the
service to the state of Massachusetts
currently at a rate of $100,000 per year
for 13 monitoring sites we measure both
beta and gamma radiation again just the
air as well as wind speed and
direction um Massachusetts state
officials dictate their desired alert
level meaning if C10 probes detect
radiation levels at or above that alert
level for a consecutive two minutes then
our system sends an automatic email and
text alert to key Department of Health
and Mima
officials representative Weber oh
sure
I'm aware of the hour and the time and
I'm also aware that I can read this
faster than you can speak it okay um and
I wonder if um perhaps a summary could
be asked for but I also wonder if uh the
person testimony testifying can be can
tell us what they think about the bill
and the provisions in the bill rather
than the background which we can all
read for ourselves sure we are we are I
think pretty much winding down on the
time limit anyway so yeah I can respect
that so goad so I'm actually was
impressed by the good car's garage sort
of um presentation it made me think you
know the relationship we have with the
state of Massachusetts is a service
contract type relationship when I looked
at this bill what stood out to me was
over $2 million in funding in a
three-year period to build a brand new
network from the ground up um I'm having
trouble wrapping my head around that as
somebody who leads an organization um
that's able to run 13 probes off
$100,000 um so I think that I would
encourage the committee and the sponsors
of this bill to to maybe work more with
the department or kind of see where some
of those numbers are coming from because
at that price point I mean I think it
would be dead on arrival um so I I just
wanted to put that's my personal thought
um and also that under section one uh
radiological monitoring of their is
absolutely critical for many reasons
outlined in here um in particular if
there was a severe weather emergency and
the NRC has stated very clearly that
that is the most likely event to push
CBR station into an emergency and that's
when you can expect traditional
infrastructure like phone and power um
to be
unavailable
okay representative Merchant has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking a question try to make
this brief in looking over the issue of
false
alarms logic sort of explains to me that
if you put more devices out into I
believe in monitoring don't get me wrong
but I'm also looking at the ability to
trigger more false alarms so how do you
balance then between having the ability
to monitor the environment for activity
but minimize the false alarms which
causes panic in a lot of
people that's a great question um and
I'll maybe clarify you know the false
alarm at CBR a CBR technician
accidentally flipped a button that had
the ability to set off sirens C10
Network or any network that DHHS or
anyone else might want to build to
provide uh radiological monitoring
creates alerts that that you can just
choose the exact people to whom those
alerts go um so when an alert level is
reached in artware network it only
alerts about four individual people
there is no public facing
alert so there's a nuclear plume there's
four people who know about it but the
rest of us don't
there is a unified command structure um
within the state of New Hampshire in
Massachusetts that dictates really
carefully how uh certain agencies would
interact with other groups to react in
an emergency I won't speak to that
that's more of uh HSM and uh maybe DHHS
as
well representative Weber you had
a okay anything anyone else any other
questions seeing none thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on hb1
1612 so I am going to close the public
hearing on this bill I'm I'm
sorry
oh is that
1612 I'm sorry I I didn't have it okay
I'm sorry apologize uh Bruce berky uh
from next era energy is U signed up to
speak sorry Mr
berky thank you Mr chairman and and U
given the hour I'll try to be very brief
this afternoon for your record my name
is Bruce berky I represent I'm I'm with
shenin capital group here in town we
represent next era energy exter energy
is the majority owner of Seabrook
station approximately 90% and the other
10% are uh owned um mostly by
municipalities in the Commonwealth
Massachusetts um just wanted to share a
few thoughts Mr baronelli mentioned uh
that this legislation had been before
this body before and it has three
different times 2018 2019 2020 and in
all three cases it was deemed uh either
inexpedient to legislate or sent to inim
study and and as being unnecessary and
the bill really isn't necessary because
of the testing and the uh radiation
monitoring that is taking place at the
station and also uh through hhs's Uh
current work and and Portsmouth and
conquered um there are uh 80 sites
within the confines of CBR station where
they have radiation monitoring uh
devices and the the feeling is that this
bill would be redundant
would add costs with no
benefit and that the um the system
that's in place at seabook station right
now is professional and 24 hours a day
365 although this year will be 366 days
a
year um they have been conducting this
work since
1982 as you may know the plant went on
online in
1990 and so they started this work in
1982 to create that Baseline prior to
cab Brook station going online so that
there would be a good um basis of work
for
comparison um it is a top priority of
Cook Station there's never been a
radiological incident associated with
cook
operations um it continuously feeds
information to the facilities control
room at the site and it is reviewed by
at least four operators that are
licensed by the nuclear Regulatory
Commission it's more extensive than
required by the
NRC and the 100 monitoring locations
because they have S sites outside of the
the uh property at seawork station um
provides a wide sampling of
sources and it's designed to detect any
radiation that could accumulate over a
period of time and that's required by
federal
law so I would ask this committee that
if it if this bill um does not go
forward that would be terrific if the if
there's some concern about this bill and
want further information uh Mr Dave
Robinson from seabook station who is the
chemistry lab manager there couldn't be
here today thus you have me um but he
could make himself available for any
subcommittee work if the committee moved
in that direction thank you that I'll
conclude my remarks thank you any
questions for Mr
berky seeing none thank you thank
you okay I'm going to try again I'm
going to close the public hearing on hb1
1612 and open the public hearing on hb1
1662 FN and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Jr hle
good afternoon chairman good afternoon
for the record representative H I'm
serving the towns of Dunbarton hookit
Allenstown and Fs I'm here to testify in
favor of House Bill 1662
dfn so I read the bill then I read the
fiscal note I'm not sure how the fiscal
note matches the bill but we'll get
there this should be a simple
housekeeping measure right we have a
department DHHS within DHHS relative to
the division of children youth and
families one of their primary
responsibilities is to place children in
New PL in new homes foster care or other
if they deem that the child is in
danger we also have adoption agencies in
the state one would think it would be an
inherent conflict of interest to have
someone who works for an adoption agency
who's also tasked with taking children
from someone's homes I would think this
is a problem that has very few actual
real world cases but a Prohibition would
make sense in this case because we don't
want to have someone incentivized to
place children outside who gets paid to
place children outside who
simultaneously is responsible for
determining whether the CH the child
that is is or may be in danger needs to
be
removed we have all sorts of
prohibitions in our statutes about
certain things this one seems like a
very logical extension in fact it I
would call it a housekeeping measure
there's no there should be no real harm
if there's people opposing this bill I
would be concerned right about this now
if I read the fiscal note I don't know
what happened um cuz the depart this is
line three in the methodology the
department states that the lure for
these entities falls under RSA 170e so
they somehow tie in the entire Foster
Care
Program this has nothing to do with the
Foster Care Program not interested in
touching the foster care program this is
primarily about someone who works for an
adoption agency as spelled out in the
text of the bill okay or a child placing
agency not a recipient in the Foster
Care Program who can't work for the
agency that helps take children from
people's homes
um so I don't know whether we go back to
the Department and ask for a
clarification on the fiscal note because
the fiscal note is is not tied to the
bill maybe they misunderstood it I don't
know but I do think that having a simple
prohibition about if you're tasked with
removing children from people's homes
then you shouldn't be also paid to place
children in other homes um can you
volunteer as an adult and and be a
foster care recipient and an employee of
the state absolutely I I I think Foster
cents are are a great attribute or a
great resource within our state um think
very highly of them they are some of the
most qualified families out there so
there's no reason I would ever want to
see a Prohibition between being a foster
care parent and being a state employee
that's not what we're talking about what
we're talking about is you're being paid
to help move a child to a new
home as
um as a job function not being because
you get reimbursed for the expenses of
being a foster care parent so maybe the
language needs to be tightened a little
bit for that I'll gladly work with
whoever on the committee wants to pick
that up that was not the intent I don't
see how we would have gotten there by
the Department's interpretation but just
in case I want to make sure that the
committee understands I'm willing to
work on the language if we need to
tighten it up it was purely about
preventing someone from helping exercise
and set up relationships for the purpose
of adoption moving children to a new
family who's also simultaneously tasked
with taking them from a family with that
I'll close my testimony and answer any
questions okay thank you representative
Weber thank you for your testimony thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for U
taking my question so am I right in
thinking from what you said that you
don't know of any actual case where this
has actually
happened I would hope that this has
never happened that doesn't mean that I
know everything so it could have
happened I'm this I am personally not
aware of any cases so this is not a bill
in response to something that I know
definitely happened but it did come up
in discussions about could it happen and
this is a reasonable prohibition to make
sure this doesn't happen children are
some of the most valuable things right
for every parent in this room You' give
your life for your child I was
discussing with um some of
the thank you other questions
seeing none thank you representative
Hall you're
welcome also signed up to speak as
Attorney John Williams with the
Department of Health and Human
Services chairman McDonald members of
the committee I started my day and I I
will end my day uh before this committee
uh the department doesn't choose which
bills that we have to do fiscal analysis
on we do receive them from the
legislative budget assistance office as
they come to us and it was really was
helpful to listen to the B Bill sponsor
represent hle at least describe what his
his goals were around it the reason why
the department had concerns relative to
its application for foster parents is
online for the bill you see that it's
targeting towards a and a licensed
adoption or child placement agency one
of the items it we identified as perhaps
a technical defect or mechanical defect
with the bill and it probably has
nothing to do with the bill sponsor and
the uh Attorneys at the office of
legislative services with the number of
bills they had to draft this year did
the best that they could and they put it
into the Department's General Authority
under
126a these licensing authorities are
actually regulated under 173 uh 170e
which also includes foster parents
that's the logical connection that the
department drew that this could have an
unintended consequence and didn't know
whether or not that that's what the bill
intended to do uh if the bill sponsor
working with this committee and
certainly working with the Department uh
makes that clear in the legislation and
perhaps uh that would be particularly
helpful to us because our concern as
currently drafted it raises lots of
issues and and in fact we would have
suggested a review by your house legal
councel uh as to the severability uh
aspect and constitutionality of such a
provision that would prevent um an
individual who's employed with DCF by by
also serving as a foster parent
particularly where those programs are
administered by separate entity
oversight other than the department so
there would not be a conflict of
interest there uh I am not a proponent
um for bills that are looking for
solutions to problems that at least
represented to you do not exist uh I was
not aware we did go through our staff
and to my knowledge we couldn't identify
any individual who is employed in a
child placement agency we did take the
extra step to look in a identify that we
do have 10 employees that do are
involved with foster care but to our
knowledge there's nobody here that would
fall in the category of working for a
child placing agency clearly I would
think and would have to agree that there
would be some level of a conflict of
interest and certainly could be looking
at that issue but it's not typical that
the legislature puts forward legislation
unless they've actually identified an
issue or potential issue and to my
knowledge over the decades and Decades
of uh placing children this this has not
been an issue at all but it was helpful
to hear theill sponsor state that this
doesn't apply to foster care because
that significantly would impact uh
certain employees and and impact morale
of certain employees at the department
as well who are currently serving in a
very important capacity as Foster
appearance so with that that concludes
my testimony but I am available for
questions I did want to acknowledge I
also have our chief Deputy legal counsel
who's here for moral support with me his
name is uh John Martin he's in the
audience here today and also helped with
this fiscal analysis um on this bill
along with our funing cial managers and
staff over at DCF thank you
representative Shapiro and then
representative
Weber representative pushman after that
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question are there other um
similar constraints on employment
outside of um the employment of of
regular DHHS employees that and how are
those and how are those enforced that's
a that's a a great question um in a
prior life I was an assistant County
attorney and there's actually
legislation in place that say you can't
be engaged in the private practice I
also understand I would defer to
attorney Martin in the gallery that
because we work for the state currently
my role is legislative nature even
though I am an active member of the
thear uh but the issue over can you do
private practice as well and I
understand there's a proabition around
it I'm just looking at John and he's
going to give me a nod yes or
no that's I have done some Pro and he
said for the viewing audience that is
correct but he has done some pro bono
work uh as well so at least that's the
one area that I could represent to you
represent Shapiro that there have been
laws in place because there might be an
inherent conflict of interest in having
somebody as an attorney serving in the
public sector but then also in the
private but I also would acknowledge in
the state of New Hampshire part-time
judges are allowed because they don't
make enough money to be able to do
private practice or at least they did
when I was actually appearing before
them so that's the only ones that I can
think of in uh State
Statute okay representative Weber and
then representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you I just wanted to ask
you um I was writing but not quickly
enough you said uh that this bill refers
to
126a and then you made a reference to a
different statute which licensed foster
parents and I was just wondering if you
would give me that reference again yeah
it contained in the Bill's fiscal
analysis which is about five times
longer than the bill to to your um um
and thank you for putting us through our
PES represent hole um and so now now
with some clarity it is in RSA chapter
170e 170
dase and it's also cited in the the
fiscal analysis representative kushman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Williams for taking my question you had
said that there is um a third party who
oversees like like Foster placement is
that right uh there is and I would just
represent you although I get involved
with pretty much everything we
practically do in the department I don't
have the the folks from the foster care
to give you the very specifics around it
but I could certainly get you in touch
with those folks who manage it because
we would not allow our employees to be
involved with being foster parents
unless they had to meet the same
criteria of any other individual serving
as a foster parent and also the issue of
you don't have the entity that is
overseeing in that employee so there is
a separation there uh that allows us to
having those employees to service Foster
um parents because we're not directly
managing whether that's done through a
procurement process we're having a third
entity that's doing it but I can have
somebody be in touch with you on the
specifics around that um I would point
out and we're happy to get you
information I'm so happy to hear that
the application here wasn't to foster
parents or foster care program thank you
I would love more information on
that other
questions see no other questions thank
you also signed up to testify is Joseph
N I believe it
is so you put down five minutes I'd
appreciate it if you could keep it
around
three yeah there you go I probably
should have put down 15 minutes um I'm
Joseph noon from hener and uh about a
year and a half ago I started to get a
uh pretty serious education on New
Hampshire DCF actually the entire
federal child protective service um
industry
itself uh with respect to this bill to
uh you know prohibit uh dcyf employees
from being involved in uh fost adoption
agencies it has come to my attention
upon uh research uh that it is
essentially a well documented um
situation in the United States where
social workers are literally looking for
babies to adopt because the adoption
Market is um basically especially for
healthy white babies uh it's like
$50,000 to adopt one of those babies and
you start doing some uh internet
research on this uh and there's a
waiting list of multiple years to even
get a baby that is especially a white
boy I have friends who have been waiting
to adopt uh kids for years for example
they explain this to me um my personal
situation with uh New Hampshire DCF is
where we had an extremely overaggressive
social worker that was uh just hellbent
for lack of a better description on uh
getting involved in our life
for I what I would call basically no
good reason in fact this is a situation
that uh right in the local town of hker
there was actually another family where
the parents were drug addicts uh kids
living in a horrible
situation and the um social workers
weren't even interested in talking to or
going about those families but in my
particular case we have clear evidence
of perjury uh at least two accounts uh
on the behalf of the social workers and
when I started asking people reaching
out to people uh for questions I got
some responses from some retired um dcyf
social workers and other people who have
been involved and targeted by
DCF um or and claim they've been
harassed by them that they're like Jay
you have and people know me as Jay but
they said Jay you have healthy children
and they are very valuable to adopt out
and that uh and a social worker in my
case who happens to be a lesbian um and
I have no problem with that situation in
fact I know multiple gay couples who
have done a fantastic job raising
adopted kids and even their biological
kids uh but they were what was expressed
to me by people who are aware of these
situations uh not only in New Hampshire
but also throughout the states is that
there's an agenda for the uh people who
essentially aren't having children for
whatever reason they have a lot of
friends that aren't having childr for
whatever reasons to come up with
valuable children to put into the
adoption system there is a documentary
if you guys would like to write this
down that I think that you should watch
it is called saving baby Cyrus and this
is a situation that happened I believe
in
Nevada um where uh essentially the baby
was taken by Child Protective Services
with with the intent to adopt out right
away and there is multiple cases of this
in fact you can internet search New
Hampshire dcyf settlements and just
start reading articles about the
liabilities that the taxpayers have had
to pay out wrapping up your testimony
yes I I'm I'm getting to that uh I
believe uh it is a a massive conflict of
interest if um uh social workers for
that work for New Hampshire DCF that
first off receive financial in
incentives uh via title 4 um are
involved with or working for uh adoption
agencies and it is also a creates
massive liability for the taxpayers and
if you uh getting to I believe the term
is um I forget what it is it's like a a
hunting for adoptive babies or something
and you start looking into that on the
internet you will see that there is
multiple situations where states have
paid out heavy heavy settlements to
children that were wrongfully taken and
put right into adoption programs quite
literally because there is just a big
Market to adopt Healthy Babies thank you
thank you any
questions seeing no questions thank you
sir uh no one else has signed up to
testify on hb1
1662 I don't see many people left here
does anyone else wish to
testify seeing no one I am going to
close the public hearing on HB
1662 those are all of the bills that we
had noticed for today so we will be
Journey for the day and reconvening next
week thank you
all